Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And my friend, Gertie Gabber of Historically Based Podcasts, Dominic Sandbrook is with me. And Dominic, today we're recording this on the 16th of February. And in 2015, Leslie Gore very sadly died. Are you a fan of Leslie Gore? do you know her greatest hit?
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。我的朋友、来自“基于历史的播客”的格蒂·加伯——多米尼克·桑德布鲁克和我在一起。多米尼克，今天我们是在2月16日录制这期节目。在2015年的今天，莱斯利·戈尔不幸逝世了。你是莱斯利·戈尔的粉丝吗？你知道她最热门的歌是什么吗？
remind me Tom, I'm struggling it's my party I will cry if I want to cry if I want to, cry if I want to you would cry too if it happened to you and you could say that at the moment would be the theme song for the British Prime Minister
提醒我一下，汤姆，我想不起来了。“这是我的派对，我想哭就能哭，我想哭就哭，我想哭就哭。如果有这种事发生在你身上，你也会哭的。”你甚至可以说，这首歌目前简直就是英国首相的主题曲。
Boris Johnson, who has endured a torrid few weeks over what the British press have called party gate. And perhaps for the benefit of our overseas listeners, you could explain exactly why these parties have been so disastrous. Well, maybe Tom, I should wait for Sue Gray's report. But since that's not forthcoming um I should say uh in the first sort of months or year or so the lockdown it is alleged that in Downing Street um Boris Johnson and his aides held an enormous quantity of of parties gatherings quizzes drinks and so on which they say are all work-related events, but it appeared to be they look very like parties
鲍里斯·约翰逊在过去几周里经历了一段艰难的时期，英国媒体称之为“派对门”。也许为了我们海外听众的利益，你可以解释一下为什么这些派对会如此灾难性？好吧，汤姆，也许我应该等苏·格雷的报告。但既然这份报告还没出来，嗯……我应该说，在封锁的最初几个月或大约一年里，据称在唐宁街，嗯，鲍里斯·约翰逊和他的助手们举行了数量惊人的派对、聚会、知识问答、酒会等等，他们声称这些全都是与工作相关的活动，但它们看起来非常像派对。
which were breaking the government's own COVID rules. So the image is of a government that was making rules for everybody else, but in which the prime minister and his aides were kind of ambushing each other with cakes and drinking cheap Prosecco and just behaving in a shameful manner. That's the sort of claim they claim this was all work related and they will be completely exonerated we will well the tension mounts tom but dominic the i mean the effect of it on the prime minister standing
这些活动违反了政府自己的新冠规定。所以人们心中的形象是，一个为其他人制定规则的政府，而首相和他的助手们却在里面用蛋糕互相恶作剧，喝着廉价的普罗塞克起泡酒，表现得十分无耻。这就是所谓的指控，他们坚称这一切都与工作有关，他们将完全被无罪释放，我们……好吧，紧张局势正在加剧，汤姆。但多米尼克，我的意思是，这件事对首相声望的影响。
and on the performance of the government in the polls has been i mean really very drastic and as as a historian of uh you know of british politics have you ever seen a meltdown quite like it? I mean, it seems to me unprecedented. Over parties? Not over parties, not over parties. But I think what it is, is to my mind, a disastrous party is a bit like a scandal. So a political scandal. So it becomes disastrous.
以及对政府在民调中的表现的影响，可以说是非常剧烈。作为一个英国政治史学家，你见过类似这样的崩盘吗？我的意思是，在我看来这似乎是空前绝后的。因为派对？不是因为派对，不是因为派对。但我觉得，在我看来，一场灾难性的派对有点像一场丑闻。也就是政治丑闻。所以它变得灾难性。
I mean, we're no strangers to disastrous parties. I imagine anybody listening to this, but a party becomes politically disastrous when it seems to throw into relief flaws or sort of anxieties that were already there. Right. Okay. So on the back of Partygate, we had a brilliant suggestion by Matt Butcher, for which we're very, very grateful, that we should do the top 10 most disastrous parties in, for which we're very, very grateful, that we should do the top 10 most disastrous parties in history, which I thought was, you know, we both thought was an absolutely brilliant idea. So that's what we've done. We put out, so I put out a tweet asking for you, the listeners, to nominate. We put it out on the Discord. And we've had hundreds and hundreds
我的意思是，我们对灾难性的派对并不陌生。我想听这个节目的任何人都是如此，但当一场派对似乎凸显了那些本已存在的缺陷或焦虑时，它就在政治上变得灾难性了。没错。好的。在“派对门”之后，马特·布彻提出了一个绝妙的建议——对此我们非常非常感激——我们应该盘点一下历史上最灾难性的十大派对，我们俩当时都觉得这是一个绝对绝妙的主意。所以这就是我们所做的。我们发布了……所以我发了一条推特，请你们这些听众来提名。我们在Discord上发布了。我们收到了成百上千个。
of nominations. We have, and we've whittled them down, haven't we? We have whittled them down. So all the ones that we've got have been suggested by you, the listeners. Boris has not made the cut. No. I was sorry that some of his colleagues who are listeners to this podcast didn't write in with nominations of their own to maybe nominate his party. Yes.
提名。确实如此，我们已经精简过了，不是吗？我们已经把它们精简了。所以我们所有的提名都是由你们这些听众提出的。鲍里斯没有入选。没有。我很遗憾，有些作为本播客听众的同僚没有写信提出他们自己的提名来提名他的派对。是的。
That secret party we had in the broom cupboard. Exactly. That nobody party we had in the broom cupboard. Exactly. That nobody found out about. Several parties were nominated that we've already had on The Rest Is History. So Tom Gorman nominated Prince Yusupov's party at the Moika Palace. Yeah, Rasputin.
我们在杂物间办的那个秘密派对。没错。谁也没发现的那个派对。没错。有些听众提名的派对我们在《历史的余烬》里已经讲过了。比如汤姆·戈尔曼提名的尤苏波夫亲王在莫伊卡宫办的派对。对，拉斯普京。
Disastrously. That was not a good party for him. Sam the Belgian has nominated Joyce and Proust meeting up, which we mentioned in the 1922 episode. Gavin Barrett, Belshazzar's Feast, which in a way is, you know, that's the archetype of a terrible party. The writing on the wall and all that kind of stuff.
结局很惨。那对他的派对来说可不是个好兆头。“比利时的萨姆”提名了乔伊斯和普鲁斯特的会面，我们在1922年的那一集里提到过。加文·巴雷特提名的伯沙撒的宴会，从某种意义上说，那可以说是糟糕派对的鼻祖。墙上的字迹之类的东西。
You don't want that to happen at your own party, do you? No, no. But I mean, I wouldn't invite Daniel to my party anyway. No. Yeah, but the whole thing about that is that, you know, the means and the person's come gate crashing in. That's true. I about that is that, you know, the means and the Persians come gatecrashing in. That's true.
你可不想这种事发生在自己的派对上，对吧？不，不。但我的意思是，无论如何我也不会邀请丹尼尔去我的派对。不。对，但整件事的关键在于，你知道，那些手段还有波斯人破门而入。确实如此。关于这一点，你知道，那些手段和波斯人突然闯了进来。确实如此。
I mean, that's, you know, very bad party. We're all familiar with the issue of gatecrashers. And then we have had several nominations that have been bubbling under. So Stephen Clarke, very much a friend of the show. Josef Sieser, am I pronouncing that right? MEP. He looks Hungarian to me, Tom. He is Hungarian.
我的意思是，你知道，这是个非常糟糕的派对。我们对不速之客的问题都习以为常。然后我们还收到了一些处于候补名单上的提名。比如斯蒂芬·克拉克，他是本节目的老朋友。约瑟夫·西泽，我发音准吗？欧洲议会议员。在我看来他像个匈牙利人，汤姆。他确实是匈牙利人。
He's a committed opponent of gay rights. Right. And inevitably, he was arrested during lockdown in Brussels, fleeing a gay sex orgy, climbing down a drainpipe. Oh, that's so off in the way. So that's quite fun. Eamon Matrfardi, absolute fixture on the Discord. The 2011 White House Correspondents' Dinner,
他是一个坚定的同性恋权利反对者。没错。而不可避免的是，他在布鲁塞尔的封锁期间被捕，当时他正从一场同性恋性爱狂欢中逃跑，顺着排水管往下爬。哦，这真是太讽刺了。所以这挺有意思的。埃蒙·马特法迪，Discord上的绝对常客。2011年的白宫记者协会晚宴。
where Obama and Seth Meyers mocked the idea of Trump running for president while he was sitting in the audience. Well, supposedly that was one of the motivating factors. Yes. Trump's determination to kind of get his own back. Absolutely. And another American one from Josh909. Andrew Jackson's inauguration. 20,000 people trashed the White House and ate a lot of cheese.
当时奥巴马和塞思·梅耶斯在特朗普坐在台下的时候，无情地嘲笑了他想要竞选总统的想法。嗯，据说那是导致他参选的动机之一。是的。特朗普要进行报复的决心。绝对是的。另一个来自美国的提名来自Josh909。安德鲁·杰克逊的就职典礼。2万人在白宫大肆破坏，还吃了很多奶酪。
And apparently the White House smelt of cheese for months. So anyway, they didn't make the cut uh nor nor dominic did a joke that about 400 people made uh i thought this was quite funny of which jack clark is representative change uk yes again for our for our overseas listeners just explain that joke i mean this is like kind of explaining a shakespeare comedy or something a very ill-fated um centrist political party formed an opposition i think largely to brexit but also to jeremy corbyn didn't do very well but there's also that party of gina millers the truth and fairness party or true and i can't remember what it's called but only six people turned up to the launch of it but not not that kind of party of course no no they're not as disastrous as our 10th choice
显然白宫里好几个月都有奶酪味。不管怎样，他们没有入选……多米尼克，大约400人都开了一个笑话，我也觉得这挺搞笑的，杰克·克拉克就是其中的代表：改变英国党。是的，同样为了我们的海外听众，解释一下那个笑话吧。我的意思是，这就像是在解释一部莎士比亚喜剧什么的。一个命运多舛的中间派政党，成立的初衷似乎主要是为了反对英国脱欧，但也反对杰里米·科尔宾，表现得不是很好。不过还有吉娜·米尔斯的那个党，叫真理与公正党还是真实与公正党，我记不清叫什么了，但它的成立仪式上只来了六个人。不过当然不是那种派对。不，不，它们没有我们的第十名那么灾难性。
well dominic should we just say say, so you and me yesterday, we went through and we kind of winnowed them down. And we're going to do it like the kind of top of the pops. We're going to go from 10 up to one. So we find out what we voted the most disastrous party of all time. So I hope you will find the tension kind of mounting as we go through. But number 10, what comes in at number 10? So it's a hunting party in the Black Forest, Tom.
好吧，多米尼克，我们是不是应该说……昨天你和我一起把它们筛选了一遍。我们打算像“流行音乐排行榜”那样来呈现。我们将从第10名倒数到第1名。来看看我们评选出的有史以来最灾难性的派对是什么。所以我希望你们在听到最后时能感受到那种紧张的气氛。那么第10名是什么呢？第10名是黑森林里的一场狩猎派对，汤姆。
They are at Donau Schwingen Castle in Donau Schwingen, Baden-Württemberg. Their date is the 14th of November, 1908. Very much a friend of the show, the Kaiser, Wilhelm II, notorious for his ill-chosen shoes. Yes. Tom Holland style shoes. And this is very much a party that revolves around ill-chosen shoes, Tom Holland-style shoes. And this is very much a party that revolves around ill-chosen dress, isn't it?
他们当时在巴登-符腾堡州多瑙欣根的多瑙欣根城堡。时间是1908年11月14日。本节目的老朋友，德皇威廉二世，以其挑选鞋子的眼光糟糕而闻名。是的。汤姆·霍兰风格的鞋子。这绝对是一场围绕着糟糕的着装、汤姆·霍兰风格鞋子展开的派对，不是吗？
It is. Well, we don't know what the Kaiser was wearing, but we do know what his old childhood friend, Count Dietrich von Hülsenheisler, was wearing. We do. I've got a printout of him. And he's a very, I think, fair to say, a Prussian-looking gentleman. He's very German. I mean, he's got the whole moustache.
确实。嗯，我们不知道德皇当时穿的是什么，但我们确实知道他童年的老朋友，迪特里希·冯·许尔森-海瑟尔伯爵当时穿的是什么。我们知道。我有一张他的照片。我觉得可以公平地说，他是一个长相很普鲁士的绅士。他非常德国。我的意思是，他留着标志性的小胡子。
He's very stolid. He's a man who's been eating sausage for decades. His jacket is festooned with medals and iron crosses, shaven-headed, square-headed. And this reminds me that this was nominated by a friend of the show dan jackson who does love a teutonic gentleman in in military uniform i've noticed from his twitter feed um so so this guy was a prussian he was the son of a general he became a general he was a childhood friend of the kaiser um and in 1889 he became the aide de camp the kaiser or should that be the aide de camp?
他非常沉稳。一看就是那种几十年来一直在吃香肠的男人。他的夹克上挂满了勋章和铁十字勋章，剃着光头，方头大耳。这让我想起，这个提名是由本节目的老朋友丹·杰克逊提出的，我从他的推特动态里注意到，他非常喜欢身穿军服的条顿绅士。嗯……所以这家伙是个普鲁士人，他是一个将军的儿子，后来自己也成了一名将军，他是德皇的童年好友。在1889年，他成了德皇的副官，或者应该叫副官？
Yes, very good. Because, so he's, I think, I believe he's the chief of the German Imperial Military Cabinet at this point, Tom. So a very important figure. And they're at Prince Max von Furstenberg's castle, as we've said, in Baden-Württemberg. And they've been hunting, haven't they? They've been hunting.
对，很好。因为，所以我认为，我相信他当时是德国帝国军事内阁的负责人，汤姆。所以这是一个非常重要的人物。正如我们所说，他们当时在符腾堡的马克斯·冯·菲尔斯滕贝格亲王的城堡里。他们去打猎了，对吧？他们去打猎了。
They've been great, great, great laughs together hunting. The Kaiser's a great huntsman. They come back and they have formal evening uh do a kind of dinner and so on and count von hülsenhäisler clearly must leave the room at some point and then really i think he's about to say he misreads the mood well you don't know. I mean, maybe he comes in and he's dressed. He's dressed in a pink tutu and ballet tights and a kind of pink leotard. He does a kind of dance of the sugar plum fairy with pirouettes and, you know, all that kind of stuff. And then he kills over of a heart attack. Supposedly he does a lot of capers and jumps.
他们一起打猎度过了非常快乐的时光。德皇是个出色的猎手。他们回来后举行了正式的晚宴等等，而冯·许尔森-海瑟尔伯爵显然在某个时刻必须离开房间，然后……真的，我想他正要说，他误判了气氛。好吧，你不知道。我的意思是，也许他走进来时盛装打扮。他穿着粉红色的芭蕾短裙和芭蕾紧身裤，还穿着一件粉红色的紧身衣。他跳起了一段糖果仙子舞，伴随着旋转跳跃，你知道的，诸如此类的东西。然后他突发心脏病倒下了。据说他做了很多滑稽的动作和跳跃。
He's an implausible ballerina it's fair to say um anyway so he has a heart attack and that's and that but yeah he does this he does this routine and then he dies and um they they call a doctor did you see this they call a doctor by the time the doctor's got there they've failed to resuscitate him and they pronounce him dead he's so he's he's succumbed to rigor mortis they had struggled to get him out of his he's obviously a really hefty he's a really hefty bloke so they they don't bury him in it no they don't but the weird thing about this tom and i said that parties when i was not laughing i said that parties were disastrous when they accentuated existing anxiety. The Kaiser and the German high command, they have been racked for the last two years by accusations of homosexuality.
公平地说，他是一个很不靠谱的芭蕾舞演员。嗯……不管怎样，他突发心脏病，然后……就那样了。他做了这一套动作然后就死了。他们叫了医生，你看到这个了吗？他们叫了医生，等医生赶到时，已经无法将他救活了，宣布他死亡。所以他已经陷入了僵硬状态。他们很难把他从衣服里弄出来。他显然是个大块头，真的是个大块头，所以他们没有把他埋在……不，没有。但奇怪的是，汤姆，正如我刚才所说，当派对加剧了原有的焦虑时，它就是灾难性的。德皇和德国最高指挥部在过去两年里一直饱受同性恋指控的折磨。
Yes, the Ullenberg scandal. Yes, exactly. An imperialist journalist, Maximilian Harden, he's accused Prince Philip of Ullenberg of being gay gay of being part of a sort of gay ring um some officers have committed suicide after being blackmailed there have been a series of libel cases and actually the kaiser has asked um count to kind of clean up the prussian high command so the weird thing is why is he doing it is he cracked under the strain and put on the tutu? Or is this a sort of elaborate in-joke? Is he maybe having a laugh in private about this sort of situation?
是的，乌伦贝格丑闻。是的，没错。一位帝国主义记者马克西米利安·哈登指控菲利普·冯·乌伦贝格亲王是同性恋，卷入了一个同性恋圈子。一些军官在被勒索后自杀，还发生了一系列诽谤官司。实际上德皇已经要求伯爵去整顿普鲁士最高指挥部。所以奇怪的是，他为什么要这么做？他是压力过大而崩溃了，所以穿上了芭蕾短裙？还是这是一个精心策划的内部笑话？他是不是在私下里对这种处境觉得很好笑？
Anyway, he's been in his tutu. He's dropped dead. It's very embarrassing. Okay, so that's not a good party. I think that we can say cast a poll over the evening and over and over the kaiser's reputation and the reputation of the german high command yeah i think that's quite a way yeah and it has been argued that you know the kaiser was left with a determination to prove his manliness that resulted in the first
不管怎样，他穿着芭蕾短裙倒下了。他突然死了。这非常尴尬。好吧，那可真不是个好派对。我想我们可以说，这给当晚的活动、德皇的声誉以及德国最高指挥部的声誉蒙上了一层阴影。是的，我认为这确实产生了影响。并且有人认为，德皇因此决心证明自己的男子气概，从而导致了第一……
world war so that's absolutely right there's a lot of literature on pre-first world war origins about manliness and gender and this sort of stuff and about the that resulted in the First World War. That's absolutely right. There's a lot of literature on pre-First World War origins about manliness and gender and this sort of stuff and about these sort of anxieties. Anyway, we don't need to go down this rabbit hole too deeply, but this is our number 10. Okay, and at number nine, nominated by Brian Spabler, we have the Fyre Festival, F-Y-R-E.
……次世界大战的爆发。所以这绝对是对的。关于第一次世界大战起源的文献中，有很多关于男子气概、性别以及这类焦虑的讨论。不管怎样，我们不需要在这个兔子洞里陷得太深，但这确实是我们的第10名。好的，排在第9位的是由布ライ恩·斯帕布勒提名的“火柴人音乐节”（Fyre Festival，又译Fyre音乐节），字母拼写是F-Y-R-E。
And Dominic, you must love this one. Blame all your darkest expectations of millennials it is a terrible behavior isn't it so the fire festival for those people who don't know it's been the subject of two rival documentaries one on netflix one by hulu um it was founded by a wikipedia claims the icon artist i think i don't know whether that's too harsh called billy mcfarland and a rapper called jar rule i'm not sure how you say it so basically they want to promote an app called of the fire app which is an app for for booking bands and they schedule this this this sort of two weekend festival in april and may 2017 on an island called
多米尼克，你一定很喜欢这个。它暴露了你对千禧一代最黑暗的期望，这真是一种糟糕的行为，不是吗？所以Fyre音乐节，对于那些不知道的人来说，它曾是两部打擂台的纪录片的主题，一部在网飞上，一部在Hulu上。维基百科称其由一个我不知道这样说是不是太苛刻的、名叫比利·麦克法兰的“标志人物”和一个叫杰·鲁的饶舌歌手创立，我不知道该怎么发音。基本上他们想推广一个叫Fyre的App，这是一个用来预订乐队的App。他们在2017年4月和5月的两个周末在巴哈马的一个叫……
great exuma in the bahamas but originally they'd been planning to have it on another island, hadn't they? That they'd kind of visited while they were on a private jet, and they'd landed on this island. And it had previously been owned by one of the leading henchmen of Pablo Escobar. That's right. And the show Narcos was then very popular in the US. So they were very excited by that. And they were told, do not publicise this using Pablo Escobar's name, that one of his henchmen. But I've seen their ad. I looked up this ad preparing for this podcast.
大埃苏马的岛屿上安排了这个音乐节。但最初他们计划把它办在另一个岛上，对吧？他们在私人飞机上参观时曾降落在那个岛上。那个岛以前属于巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的一个主要爪牙。没错。当时美剧《毒枭》在美国非常受欢迎。所以他们对此感到非常兴奋。有人告诉他们，千万不要用巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的名字来宣传，不要提他的爪牙。但我看过他们的广告。为了准备这个播客，我特意去查了这个广告。
It's still there. It's a real sort of Instagrammers kind of ad. And on the ad, it says explicitly, on an island owned by Pablo Escobar, which is just untrue. Pablo Escobar did not own this island. But that's why they then have,
它现在还在。那是一种非常典型的Instagram风格的广告。广告上明确写着：“在巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔拥有的岛屿上”，这完全是谎言。巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔根本不拥有这个岛。但这就是他们后来遇到的……
that's the problem, because the people who own it are furious and kick them off. So they then have to go and find some other place and they go to Great Exuma. And, you know, that's fine. They book in. But the problem is that the Exuma regatta is going on at the same time. Everyone has booked up all the hotels. That's right. Yeah. And they've kind of promised incredible luxury.'ve got loads of um kind of instagram stars are you familiar with all these people tom kendall jenner you're familiar with the work of kendall jenner uh daughter of um the jenners related to greg jenner the podcaster yes uh bella hadid are you willing to follow her work big fan uh hayley baldwin emily ratay
这就是问题所在，因为岛的拥有者勃然大怒，把他们赶走了。所以他们不得不去寻找另一个地方，于是他们去了大埃苏马。你知道，这倒也行。他们预订好了。但问题是埃苏马帆船赛正好在同一时间举行。所有的酒店都被订满了。没错。是的。他们承诺了令人难以置信的奢华。他们找了大量的……Instagram明星。汤姆，你熟悉这些人吗？肯达尔·詹娜，你熟悉肯达尔·詹娜的作品吗？詹娜的女儿，和播客格雷格·詹娜有亲戚关系。是的。贝拉·哈迪德，你愿意关注她的作品吗？狂热粉丝。海莉·鲍德温，艾米丽·拉塔……
ratay kowski i know i see that name in mail online all the time but i don't know who it is anyway they were all they were all paid to advertise it and then there was a scandal over that but basically did you see the list of acts are you familiar with the acts you're not familiar with the work of pusher t designer with two eyes no scepter clap tone what about lee burridge are you well lee burridge sounds like he plays in golf in Northampton Town, I think, compared with the others. Lee Burridge, that's the worst name. It is.
……拉塔科夫斯基。我知道我经常在《每日邮报》网站上看到这个名字，但我不知道她是谁。不管怎样，他们都被付钱去宣传这个活动。然后就爆发了一场丑闻。但基本上，你看了演出名单吗？你熟悉这些演出阵容吗？你不熟悉Pusher T的作品吧？Designer（名字带两个s）？还有Scepta、Clapton？李·伯里呢，你……嗯，李·伯里听起来像是在北安普敦镇打高尔夫球的，和另外那些人相比。李·伯里，这名字太逊了。确实。
It's not a great name. Anyway, they didn't turn up, all these bands. I mean, some of them hadn't even been booked. It was all a complete con. The best part of this con, actually, was that they told, the organizers told people who bought tickets, it will be cashless and cardless. So basically, you have to give us lots of money now, and we'll send you a bracelet with your money on it and this was a sort of wireless it
这名字可真不怎么样。不管怎样，这些乐队根本没有出现。我的意思是，其中一些人甚至根本没被预订。整个就是一个彻头彻尾的骗局。其实这个骗局最棒的部分在于，组织者告诉那些买票的人，这将是一个无现金、无银行卡的音乐节。基本上，你现在必须给我们很多钱，然后我们会寄给你一个存有你资金的手环，这是一种无线……
would work by wi-fi but when the people got to the islands there's no wireless on the island so there's no there's nowhere to stay no they all stayed they kind of got a tense but they weren't enough tents to go around united nations tentse tents. And they gave them cheese sandwiches. Yeah. So the reason this is resonant, I think, is because it's 2017 and it seemed to – I mean, there was enormous quantities of schadenfreude. A lot of the people who paid up, hundreds, 5,000 people, had to be sort of flown out, had to be like refugees.
它可以通过Wi-Fi运作。但当人们到达岛上时，岛上根本没有Wi-Fi，所以根本没有地方住。没有，他们都住进了……他们弄到了一些帐篷，但帐篷根本不够分。联合国式的帐篷。他们给他们吃的是奶酪三明治。是的。所以这件事之所以引起共鸣，我认为是因为那是2017年，它似乎——我的意思是，当时有大量的幸灾乐祸。许多付了钱的人——几百人，5000人——不得不被空运撤离，看起来就像难民一样。
And I think this thing about parties or scandals throwing things into relief it was seen as the sort of you know the the the self-delusion of the instagram generation right so it's all about instagram because the whole thing was designed to look good on instagram so that was why it was instagram influencers advertising it and so the fact that it then turned out to be you know you were camped out in a cesspool with a cheese sandwich was everybody who hadn't gone well everybody adored it basically yeah everybody over the age but you were camped out in a cesspool with a cheese sandwich. Everybody who hadn't gone absolutely adored it. Basically, everybody over the age of 35 thought it was just absolutely the best thing that had happened.
我认为，关于派对或丑闻能够将某些东西衬托得淋漓尽致这一点，它被视为……你知道的，Instagram一代的自我欺骗。没错，这一切都是为了Instagram，因为整个活动的设计就是为了在Instagram上看起来很美，所以才会有Instagram网红来做广告。因此，当结果证明你实际上是睡在粪坑里、吃着奶酪三明治时，所有没去的人……好吧，没去的人绝对爱死了。基本上，所有35岁以上的人都认为这是发生过的最棒的事情。
But I think also people who would have loved to go also enjoyed it because they hadn't, and they dodged a bullet. Well, this is true. Do you not feel like that? I mean, I'm not a natural festival goer. I don't think that'll surprise any of the audience to hear that. Whenever I, you know, when I was in my 20s and I used to see news footage of a deluge at glastonbury and people you know trudging miserably through torrents of mud i always used to think i'm so happy they're there and i'm here but i think there's a difference
但我也觉得，那些本来很想去的人其实也很高兴自己没去，因为他们躲过了一劫。好吧，这倒也是。难道你没有这种感觉吗？我的意思是，我不是那种天生喜欢去音乐节的人。我想听众听到这里都不会觉得惊讶。每当我……你知道的，当我20多岁的时候，看到格拉斯顿伯里音乐节遭遇暴雨、人们痛苦地蹚着泥泞 torrents 的新闻画面时，我总是会想：我太高兴他们在那里而我在这里了。但我觉得这有所不同。
because you expect that at glastonbury and that's kind of factored in as part of the fun that's true and actually you know there's nothing you know kate moss in a pair of boots wandering around that's that's absolutely what is going to look good on instagram but the thing about this was that essentially you know you you pay an enormous amount of money to look like you know a refugee basically yeah and it was the contract it was the contrast of what was sold and then what was so jar rule tweeted it was not a scam. This is not my fault. And the official statement said, due to circumstances out of our control, the physical infrastructure was not in place on time
因为你在格拉斯顿伯里会预料到那种情况，这已经被当作乐趣的一部分考虑进去了。确实如此。而且实际上，你知道，凯特·莫斯穿着一双靴子到处闲逛，那绝对是在Instagram上看起来会很棒的样子。但这件事的特别之处在于，本质上，你花了巨额的钱，结果看起来像个难民。没错。这就是销售宣传和实际情况之间的反差。所以杰·鲁发推特说：这不是一场骗局。这不是我的错。官方声明则称：由于超出我们控制范围的情况，基础设施没有按时到位，我们无法为宾客提供安全愉快的愿景。好吧，主要负责人被判入狱了。六年。六年。是的。所以给我们的教训是：除非是历史节，否则不要去参加音乐节。
and we are unable to fulfill on our vision safely and enjoyably for our guests. Well, the main guy was sent to prison. Six years. Six years. Yeah. So the lesson for that, don't go to a festival unless it's a history festival.
让我们继续看……第8名。第8名是一个我甚至能在Fyre音乐节上想象到的人：年轻的彼得大帝。这是由西蒙·格德尔斯顿提名的。我把它直接读出来好了，因为真的没什么好补充的了。西蒙说：“我提名彼得大帝在1698年逗留于约翰·伊夫林在德特福德的家——塞斯考特。在此期间，彼得和他的随行人员（70名士兵、4名侏儒、一个厨师、一个牧师和一只猴子）消耗了大量的烈酒，烧毁了所有的家具来当柴烧（包括所有50把椅子），把全部25幅精美画作当成靶子练习射击，砸毁了所有的门和锁，把地毯和地板搞得满是油污以至于全部报废，甚至有三层楼不得不完全拆除重建，砸碎了300块窗玻璃，毁坏了伊夫林花了20年才在花园里培育出来的所有树篱，还把独轮车拿来搞酒后竞速赛，把它们全都撞坏了。”差不多就是这样。所以彼得大帝正在他的西方大游历途中。他来到了伦敦。他想去参观造船厂。
Let's move on to uh number eight number eight a man who actually i can kind of see at the fire festival the young peter the great young peter the great and this was suggested by uh simon girdleston um and i'm just going to read it read it out because really there's there's very little to add to it so simon i nominate peter the great stay at john evelyn's house sales court in detford in 1698, in which Peter and his entourage of 70 soldiers, four dwarfs, a cook, a priest and a monkey, consumed a colossal volume of spirits, burned all the furniture for firewood, including all 50 chairs, used all the 25 fine pictures for target practice, smashed all the doors and locks, left the carpets and floors covered in such a layer of grease that all were ruined and three floors had to be ripped up entirely, broke 300 window panes and smashed all the hedges in the garden that it had taken evil in 20 years to grow, as well as all the wheelbarrows by using them in drunken races. That's pretty much it. So Peter the Great is on his grand tour of the West. He's come to London. He wants to look at the shipyards,
但一切都在……那是1698年的冬天。他先去了阿姆斯特丹，对吧？完全正确。这就是威廉三世作为英格兰国王的时候，或者随便什么……他是荷兰的奥兰治亲王。奥兰治亲王在荷兰。所以他随后赶到了伦敦。泰晤士河结冰了，一切都冻住了。人们在冰上溜冰、卖馅饼。由于人群源源不断地跑去看彼得大帝，他便离开了。他个子非常高，不是吗？而且他当时穿着伪装，所以每个人都假装认不出他不是真的他，但他实在太高了。著名的17世纪日记作家约翰·伊夫林已经打理这个花园45年了，他精心修剪的花园是他的骄傲和喜悦。而他把这里转租了出去。
but everything is, it's the winter of 1698. goes to he goes to amsterdam first doesn't he does exactly and this is when william the third is king of he's king of england and he's whatever yeah holder is he prince uh prince of orange prince of orange in the netherlands so the he then comes to london the thames is frozen everything is frozen people are skating and selling pies on the ice and uh basically because crowds keep coming to look at Peter the Great he goes off he's incredibly tall isn't he and he's in disguise so everyone's pretending it's not really him but he's so tall and John Evelyn the uh diarist very famous 17th century diarist he's been been he's been doing looking after this garden for 45 years laying out the the hedges, which are his pride and joy. And he sublet it.
租给了彼得大帝。不，不，不，他没有转租。哦，不。他把房子转租给别人了。本博海军上将。是的，然后本博又转租给了彼得大帝. 所以他们实际上从来没有见过面。没有。
To Peter the Great. No, no, no, he hasn't sublet it. Oh, no. He sublet it to somebody else. Admiral Benbow. Yes, who then sublet it to Peter the Great. So they never actually meet. No.
而且有一次，伊夫林的管家写信给伊夫林。他说，房子里挤满了人，而且弄得很脏。是的，差不多就是这样。这正是发生的事情。所以他 실제로 请了克里斯托弗·雷恩和皇家园丁去房子里检查房屋状况并评估损失。是的。
And at one point, actually, Evelyn's steward writes to Evelyn. He says, the house is full of people and write nasty. Yeah, well, that's up. Yeah. And this is exactly what happened. So he actually gets Christopher Wren and the Royal Gardener to go to the house to examine the state and to assess the damage. Yeah.
情况正如你所说，瓷砖全被砸碎了。窗户全被打破了。房子里原本有50把椅子，每一把都被砸碎了。画作全部被用来当靶子练习。还有他们的花园，我认为那是最大的问题，因为这个树篱被人们用独轮车疯狂撞击并赛车而彻底摧毁了。显然他们以前经常做的事情是把沙皇塞进独轮车里，推着他往树篱里冲。好吧，任何看过美剧《凯瑟琳大帝》中关于她与彼得三世婚姻情节的人都会对此感到熟悉。
And it's exactly as you say, the tiles have all been smashed. The windows have all been broken. There are 50 chairs in the house and every one of them has been smashed. The pictures have all been used for target practice. And's their garden i think that's the big issue because this hedge has been utterly destroyed by people ramming wheelbarrows into it and having races and now apparently what they used to do was they would put the czar in the wheelbarrow and race him into the hedges well anyone who's seen the great about uh catherine the great and her marriage to peter the III will recognise this.
这里的类比有点像是父母周末外出，他们的孩子在Facebook上发帖办了个派对，结果一大群俄罗斯人涌了进来……以及独轮车赛。向任何俄罗斯听众道歉。我相信有很多俄罗斯听众比彼得大帝守规矩得多。不管怎样，损失金额是350英镑又9便士。
The analogy here is sort of parents going away for the weekend and their children advertise a party on Facebook and a load of Russians turn up and... Wheelbarrow racing. Apologies to any Russian listeners. I'm sure there are plenty of Russian listeners who are much better behaved than Peter the Great was. But anyway, £350 and ninepence was the damage.
而且，你知道的，我没有做换算，但在17世纪这可是一笔巨款。所以，这是三场无人死亡的派对。是的。但除非发生某种残酷的谋杀案，否则这算不上是一场真正灾难性的派对。等等。不，不，不。那家伙之前就死了。
And that, you know, I haven't done the conversion, but that's a colossal amount of money in 17th century terms. So those are three in which nobody died. Yeah. But it's not really a disastrous party unless there's a kind of brutal killing. Well, hold on. No, no, no. That bloke died before.
穿芭蕾短裙的那个人。他当然死了。是的，他确实死了。抱歉。是的，他死了。但他不是被谋杀的。不，还没有人被谋杀，这有点让人失望。所以现在我们来到了第一场涉及谋杀的派对，实际上是好几起谋杀……这就是那个名字绝妙的……
The tutu man. Of course he did. Yes, he did. Yes. Apologies. Yes, he did. But he wasn't murdered. No, nobody's murdered anybody yet which is disappointing so now we come to our first party that involved a murder in fact a few murders um and this is the brilliantly named
罗斯基勒血宴。正如纽加德所建议的——我猜这可能是一个丹麦听众——我想是的。所以在12世纪的丹麦，对吧？1157年8月9日。但多米尼克，这一切的根源可以追溯到我们在1066年那一集里涵盖的事件。它涉及斯文二世，他是丹麦国王，在1067年或1069年派遣了最后一次可以被称为维京探险的远征去攻打英格兰。
blood feast of roskilde and as new guard has suggested this who i'm imagining is perhaps a danish listener i should think so yeah um so in 12th century denmark aren't we yeah uh ninth of Newgard has suggested this. Who I'm imagining is perhaps a Danish listener. I should think so, yeah. So in 12th century Denmark, aren't we? Yeah, 9th of August, 1157. But the roots of this, Dominic, lie in events that we covered in our 1066 episode. So it involves Fane II, who was the king of Denmark
他曾是我们在节目里经常谈到的哈拉尔·哈德拉达的死对头。但除此之外，他还生了大量的孩子。
who sent the very last kind of what could be called a Viking expedition in I think 1067 1069 that's right against England and he'd been
他们彼此之间闹翻了，所以这就像爱德华三世一样。非常相似。你知道的，这就像是带有延迟余震的玫瑰战争。这是丹麦版的玫瑰战争。所以在这次血宴发生时，有三个互相争夺王位的竞争者，对吧？是这样吗？
the great rival of Harald Hardrada who we've talked about quite a lot but the other thing he does is he has enormous quantities of children
嗯，这再次呼应了英格兰的玫瑰战争。所以在1146年，丹麦的埃里克三世退位并隐修到了一座修道院里。他就是那种人。你知道他的绰号是什么吗？“羔羊”埃里克。我想他是“令人难忘的”埃里克，对吧？是吗？
and they all fall out with each other so it's like Edward III. Very much. You know, with a kind of delayed aftershock with the Wars of the Roses. This is the Danish equivalent. So there are three rival claimants, aren't there, by the point of this blood feast. Is that right?
好吧，从他显然不那么令人难忘这一点来看……嗯，我想他因做出灾难性的决定而令人难忘。好吧，请继续。因为他退位了，出现了三个候选人。显然在丹麦的国王名单中，他们都被记作国王。他们的统治时期都重叠了，完全如此。
Well, again, the echo of Wars of the Roses in England. So in 1146, Eric III of Denmark abdicates and retires to a monastery. So he's that kind of guy. Do you know what his sobriquet is? Eric the Wet. I think he's Eric the Memorable, isn't he? Is he? Yeah.
所以你有斯文三世。对，当然是斯文三世。克努特五世，瓦尔德马一世。基本上这三个国王互相打了11年。然后他们在……
Well, the fact that he can't clearly isn't that memorable. Well, I suppose memorable for a disastrous decision. Well, go on. Because he abdicates and there are three alternative candidates. Yeah. And apparently in kind of Danish, Danish lists of kings, they're all remembered as kings. They all overlap, exactly.
洛兰开会。这有点像《李尔王》。他们决定把王国分成三份，并通过发誓来确认这项条约。然后他们……斯文邀请另外两个国王去罗斯基勒参加一个派对。绝对是群大笨蛋。我去过罗斯基勒很多次。那里有一座非常棒的船帆……
So you've got Svein II. No, Svein III. Svein III. Yes, of course, Svein III. Knut V, Voldemar I. Yeah. And basically these three kings all fight each other for 11 years. And then they held council in
……博物馆。对，船博馆。我强烈推荐。还有一座伟大的大教堂。非常漂亮。红砖砌成的那种大教堂，不是吗？这一切都是一个陷阱。克努特被杀了。瓦尔德马大腿受伤，但逃跑了，设法逃脱了。
Lolland. And it's a bit like King Lear. They decided to divide the kingdom into three. And they confirmed the treaty by an oath. And then they... Svein invites the other two kings to a party in Roskilde. Absolute idiots. I've been to Roskilde a ton. Fantastic ship
几个月后，他带着大军杀了回来。他击败了斯文，然后成为了“大帝”瓦尔德马。所以这就叫经典的套路。斯文邀请他们去参加派对，然后斯文说：“我得出去一下。”基本上，在中古欧洲，如果一个跟你结有深仇大恨的人对你这么说，你还留在那里跟他的士兵鬼混，那你真是疯了。而这正是发生的事情。他手下有个叫德特弗的人，开始捅所有人。但愚蠢的是没有把瓦尔德马也干掉，因为瓦尔德马逃跑了，不是吗？
museum. Yeah, ship museum. I heartily recommend it. A great cathedral. Very nice. Red brick kind of cathedral, isn't it? This is Fantastic ship museum. Yeah, ship museum. I heartily recommend it. A great cathedral. Very nice. Red brick kind of cathedral, isn't it? This is all a trap. Canuck gets killed. Voldemort gets wounded in the thigh but runs away, manages to escape. Yeah.
他随后在格拉塔希德战役中与斯文交战。斯文逃跑了，被一群愤怒的农民杀死。瓦尔德马成为了丹麦国王，这么说没错吧？所以基本上，千万别去参加丹麦国王举办的派对。瓦尔德马成了一位非常成功的国王。
And a few months later, he comes back with a big army. He defeats Svein and he then becomes Voldemort the Great. Yeah. So there's a man called, it's that classic thing. Svein has invited them to the party and then spain says um i just have to pop out for a second basically if somebody you've been feuding with does that to you in medieval europe you're absolutely mad to say oh yeah well i'll hang around here with your soldiers till yeah which is exactly what happens he has a man called detlef who's just starts stabbing everybody um but the folly is not to kill voldemar as well, because Valdemar escapes,
他痛击了文德人，那些异教徒从来不做任何不咨询会说话的马的事情。哇。那有点像托勒密一世和他的会说话的蛇。会说话的动物绝对是本播客的一大特色。所以接下来是第6名。
doesn't he? He then fights Svein at the Battle of Gratahede. Svein runs away. He's killed by a mob of angry peasants. And Valdemar becomes king of Denmark, is that easy to say? So basically, don't go to a party with a Danish king. And Valdemar becomes a very successful king
我们第6名是什么？第6名，具体来说，我们要前往埃及，在1811年春天的开罗。一个名叫穆罕默德·阿里的阿尔巴尼亚裔军阀——不是那个拳王——厌倦了马木鲁克。马木鲁克是统治埃及的突厥裔武士阶层。就是我们在《拿破仑在埃及》里讲过的那些。没错。
and he smites the Wens, who were pagans, who never did anything without consulting a talking horse. Wow. That's a bit like Ptolemy I and his talking snakes. Yeah. Talking animals are very much a feature of this podcast. So number six.
所以这是我们之前播客《拿破仑在埃及》的续集。埃及恢复了名义上的奥斯曼统治。穆罕默德·阿里想把埃及据为己有。他厌倦了马木鲁克。按照那种非常常见、并且在这个播客里也将屡见不鲜的经典套路，解决他们的办法就是邀请他们所有人来参加一个派对。现在，他们人数众多。
Yeah. What have we got at six? So number six, specifically, we're heading to Egypt, and we are heading to Cairo in the spring of 1811. An Albanian kind of warlord called Muhammad Ali, not the boxer, is sick of the Mamluks. The Mamluks are the Turkic kind of warrior class that have been running Egypt. Who are in Napoleon in Egypt. Exactly.
有几百人。他们是武士精英，几个世纪以来埃及的统治者基本上都是从他们当中通过这种血腥的竞争挑选出来的或脱颖而出的。汤姆，你想讲讲马木鲁克后来遭遇了什么故事吗？嗯，这是他儿子的生日派对，这是一个极其精妙的转折。他在城堡里举办了这个派对。去过开罗的人都知道，那正是你对开罗城堡所期待的一切。那里有一条非常陡峭狭窄的通道，连接着堡垒的高处和下方的城门。所以他们去了那里，享受派对。
So this is the sequel release in Napoleon in Egypt, our earlier podcast. Egypt has reverted to sort of nominal Ottoman rule. Muhammad Ali wants to basically take it over for himself. He's sick of the Mamluks. And in that classic way that is so common, it's going to be so common in this podcast, the way to do it is to invite them all to a party. Now, there's a lot of them.
他们享用派对蛋糕、玩游戏、传包裹。有很多甜点，这正是我对埃及派对的期待。当然。然后他们开始排着队沿着这条陡峭狭窄的通道往下走。阿尔巴尼亚人砰地关上了大门。马木鲁克们骑着马往下走，结果被困在了这条通道里。
There's hundreds of them. They are this sort of warrior elite from whose ranks for centuries the Egyptian the masters of Egypt have basically been been chosen or emerged through this sort of bloody competition and Tom do you want to tell the story of what happens to the Mamluks well it's his his son's birthday party which is the the kind of exquisite twist and he holds this in the citadel anyone who's been to Cairo it's kind of. Everything that you'd expect the citadel of Cairo to be. And it has a very steep, narrow passage that connects the kind of upper reaches of the fort to the lower gate. So they go there and they enjoy the party.
所以他们成了活靶子，全部被消灭了……或者说，传说其中一个人骑着马跳过了城墙？马死了，但他设法逃脱了，他是唯一的幸存者。是的，但那就是那个故事。所以那绝对不是一个好派对。而且我认为可以公平地说，伊斯兰历史上的朝代更迭经常以可怕的派对为特色。所以最初的伍麦叶王朝是第一个伊斯兰王朝。他们被阿拔斯王朝消灭了，阿拔斯王朝后来建立了巴格达。最后一个伍麦叶哈里发马尔万再次被追击到埃及，被逼入绝境后丧命，他的头颅被送给了阿拔斯王朝，他们把他的舌头喂了一只猫。但随后，他们急于围捕剩下的伍麦叶王室成员。
They enjoy the party cake and the games and pass the parcel. There's lots of sweetmeats, which is exactly what I expect from an Egyptian party. They enjoy the party cake and the games and pass the parcel. There's a lot of sweetmeats, which is exactly what I expect from an Egyptian party. Of course. And then they all start filing down this steep, narrow passage. And the Albanians slam the doors shut. The Mamluks are going down on their horses. And they're trapped in this passageway.
于是他们把他们全抓起来，刺死他们，然后把他们当作……某种派对的基础。他们用毯子盖住尸体，在上面摆满各种地毯、长椅、点心和甜品，然后他们所有人都在上面坐着，甚至还能听到那些人慢慢断气时的呻吟声。所以我想……我想如果你是个阿拔斯人，这倒是个很棒的派对；但如果你是个伍麦叶人，这就是个可怕的派对。汤姆，其实当我们在起草这个名单时，我有点遗憾我们选了这个而不是查帕奎迪克。但现在我觉得这比查帕奎迪克更棒、更灾难性。是的，它可能确实如此。我们以后还得回过头来讲讲查帕奎迪克。泰德·肯尼迪相当黑暗的时刻。
And so they're easy game. And they all get wiped out or do they the story goes that one of them jumps over the wall on his horse on his horse and the horse dies but he manages to get away and he's the only survivor yeah but but that's the that's the story so that's not a good party um and i i think it's fair to say that dynastic change in Islamic history often features terrible parties. So the very first one, the Umayyads are the first Islamic dynasty. And they get eliminated by the Abbasids who go on to found Baghdad. And the last Umayyad caliph, Marwan, gets pursued again to Egypt, gets cornered, killed, head gets sent to the Abbasids, and they feed his tongue to a cat. But they then, they're anxious to round up the remaining Umayyads.
嗯，不仅是他黑暗的时刻，也是玛丽·乔·科佩特内黑暗的时刻，我想我们以后会做一期播客的。是的，我们会的。一定会的。
Yeah. And so they get them all, and they stab them, and then they use them as a kind uh the foundation for a party so they drape them with carpets and put all the kind of you know the couches and the treats the sweetmeats and things and that they all lie there and they can hear the groans of the maids as they slowly expire so i suppose i mean i suppose that's a great party if you're an aborted but it's a it's a terrible party if you're an aborted see tom i was actually uh when we were drafting this, I was a bit gutted that we chose that and not Chappaquiddick. But now I think that is a better party,
好了，我们的前十名已经过半了。紧张气氛正在加剧。我想此时我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将公布前五名。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史就是娱乐》。
a more disastrous party than Chappaquiddick. Yes, I think it probably is. We have to come back to Chappaquiddick in the future. Ted Kennedy's rather darkest hour. Well, not just his darkest hour, but Mary Jo Capetna's darkest hour in a future podcast, I think. Yes, we will. Definitely.
比查帕奎迪克更灾难性的聚会。是的，我想可能确实如此。我们以后必须回过头来谈谈查帕奎迪克。泰德·肯尼迪相当黑暗的时刻。嗯，不仅是他的黑暗时刻，我想也是玛丽·约·卡佩特纳在未来播客中的黑暗时刻。是的，我们会的。一定的。
Right. So we're halfway through the top 10. Tension is mounting. I think at this point we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll be giving the top five. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
好的。所以我们已经完成了前十名的一半。气氛越来越紧张。我认为在这一点上我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将公布前五名。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now now before we continue with history's most disastrous parties we want to let you know that we are going to let you the listeners choose the topic of an
这是一个关于娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八卦的每周合辑。在我们的问答环节中，我们将带你一探娱乐产业的幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获得额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《闲来史事》。在我们将要继续讲述历史上最灾难性的派对之前，我们要告诉大家，我们将让你们——听众朋友们——来决定一个
upcoming episode what could possibly go wrong so we've had billions of episode suggestions on twitter and on email and on our Discord chat room for the Restless History Club members over the last few months. And we have narrowed them down to the four, the big four options, and we want you, the listeners, to decide. So Tom, would you like to unveil the shortlist? Number one, The Historical Jesus, suggested by Joe Evans-Green. Number two, The Winter of Discontent in the late 70s by Roy Nelly. Number three, Top Sidekicks. So that's Agrippa, Eden, Keith Joseph, and that's suggested by Simon Girdleston. And number four, The Special Relationship. So I guess that's Britain and
即将播出的单集的选题。这还能出什么岔子呢？过去几个月里，我们在推特、电子邮件以及“闲来史事俱乐部”会员的 Discord 聊天室里收到了海量的选题建议。我们已经将它们筛选出了四个，也就是最重要的四个选项，我们希望由你们——听众朋友们——来做决定。那么，汤姆，你愿意揭晓入围名单吗？第一名，历史上的耶稣，由乔·埃文斯-格林（Joe Evans-Green）提出。第二名，70年代末的不满之冬，由罗伊·内利（Roy Nelly）提出。第三名，顶级副手。也就是阿格里帕、伊甸、基思·约瑟夫，由西蒙·吉德尔斯顿（Simon Girdleston）提出。第四名，特殊关系。我想这指的是英国和
America, and that's suggested by amy mantrovadi so there you have it the historical jesus the winter of discontent top sidekicks and the special relationship and if you want to get involved it is a bit like choosing a party leader it is one person one vote we don't have a trade union block vote in the rest is history but you do have to be a a member of the rest is history club whether you call yourself a wang a friend of the show or an athelstan doesn't matter but you have to be part of the club to vote. So go to restishistorypod.com, you sign up to the Discord, and then you click on the polls channel to cast your vote. The poll is now live, and it will be until Wednesday evening, and we will announce the
美国，由艾米·曼特罗瓦迪（Amy Mantrovadi）提出。所以，这就是全部候选：历史上的耶稣、不满之冬、顶级副手和特殊关系。如果你想参与进来，这有点像挑选党魁，一人一票。在《闲来史事》里我们可没有什么工会集团投票，但你必须是“闲来史事俱乐部”的会员——无论你自称是王迷（wang）、节目之友还是埃塞尔斯坦（athelstan）都没关系，但你必须是俱乐部的一员才能投票。所以，请前往 restishistorypod.com，注册加入 Discord，然后点击投票（polls）频道投下你的一票。投票现已开始，并将持续到周三晚上，我们将在下周的节目中宣布
winning topic on next week's episode, and we will then think about when we're going to record it. So welcome back to The Rest is History. We're all about parties this week. We've done some of the top 10 most disastrous parties in history. We are approaching our top five. Tom, a great character awaits us now. One of my favourite Roman emperors, Elagabalus. Yes. Sun worshing uh by all accounts
获胜的主题，然后我们会考虑什么时候录制它。欢迎回到《闲来史事》。我们这周的主题全是关于派对。我们盘点了历史上最灾难性的前10大派对中的一部分。我们正在接近前5名。汤姆，一个了不起的人物正在等待着我们。我最喜欢的罗马皇帝之一，埃拉伽巴尔斯（Elagabalus）。是的。崇拜太阳神，呃，据各方描述
a dreadful man though perhaps much maligned by the i'm basing this on the augustan history which i i suspect you will tell me is pure propaganda so what century are we in first we are we're in the early third century um so the the age of the antonine peace is uh coming to an end in fact elegabalus is is the last of the Antonine in that particular family he reigns 218 to 222 and as you say the main source for his life
这是一个可怕的家伙，尽管可能被严重诋毁了，因为我是基于《奥古斯都历史》得出这个看法的，而我猜你会告诉我这纯粹是政治宣传？那么我们现在是在哪个世纪呢？我们是在公元三世纪初，呃，安东尼和平时期正走向尾声。事实上，埃拉伽巴尔斯是那个特定家族中最后一个安东尼王朝成员。他在位时间是218年至222年，正如你所说，关于他生平的主要来源
is the Augustan history and the account that it gives is very very lurid that's putting it mildly so yes so Elagabalus is according to this biography of him in the Augustan history, very much a party animal. So he likes to dress up as Venus.
就是《奥古斯都历史》，其中记载的内容非常非常耸人听闻，这还只是委婉的说法。所以，是的，根据《奥古斯都历史》中为他写的这篇传记，埃拉伽巴尔斯绝对是个派对动物。所以他喜欢把自己打扮成维纳斯。
He's reputedly the first emperor to wear nothing but silk. That's right, yeah. He lolls around on cushions that are filled with rabbit fur. He's also made entirely of silver. He feeds his dogs on cushions that are filled with rabbit fur. He's made entirely of silver. He feeds his dogs on foie gras. He only swims in perfumed swimming pools. He has a chariot drawn by kind of female ponies. So women who, you know,
据说他是第一个只穿丝绸衣服的皇帝。没错了，是的。他懒洋洋地躺在塞满兔子毛的靠垫上。他全身也完全是由白银制成的。他用塞满兔子毛的靠垫来喂他的狗。他全身完全是由白银制成的。他用鹅肝喂他的狗。他只在香水游泳池里游泳。他的战车由一种雌性小马拉着——也就是那些，你知道的，
are bitted and bridled and human ponies. But he's a japester. Well, some of these details are absolutely preposterous. So some of this, and this reading from the Augustan history, some of his humbler friends, he would seat on air pillows instead of on cushions.
戴着嚼子和缰绳的人形小马。但他是个爱开玩笑的人。嗯，其中一些细节简直荒谬绝伦。所以其中的一部分——这是从《奥古斯都历史》中读到的——他会让他的一些地位较低的朋友坐在气垫而不是靠垫上。
And he would let out the air while they were dining. So that often the diners were suddenly found under the table. I mean, that's just, that's only a step up from a whoopee cushion. But if you, but if you get that, you get off lightly.
然后在他们用餐时把气放掉。以至于常常是就餐者突然发现自己掉到了桌子底下。我的意思是，这只比放屁垫（whoopee cushion）高明了一步。但如果你——如果你遇到这个，你还算走运了。
Yeah. Well, because... Well, so another gag of his was to invite people to massive banquets, but the food that they were given was made entirely out of wax or wood or pottery or whatever, where he'd have real food and he'd be guzzling away. They'd just have to stare at it and then pretend that they'd eaten. But the worst was if he invited you to stay overnight oh yeah and he'd get you hammered he'd get hammered and then and then he'd say i've procured you the most skillful and beautiful
是的。因为……好吧，所以他的另一个恶作剧是邀请人们参加盛大的宴会，但给他们的食物完全是用蜡、木头或陶器等做成的，而他自己则有真正的食物在大快朵颐。他们只能盯着那些东西，然后假装自己已经吃过了。但最糟糕的是，如果他邀请你留宿过夜——哦，是的，他会灌醉你，他会把你灌醉，然后——然后他说：“我为你物色了世界上最熟练、最美丽
courtesans in the world uh and and leave the lights off and they'd wake up and discover that they were withered old crones yeah old hags from ethiopia yes in the august but i thought you were going to say what he does is um it says here when his friends became drunk he would shut them up and suddenly during the night he would let in his lions and leopards and bears so that's the ultimate so that all of them harmless because they'd obviously had their teeth taken out or something so that his friends on awakening at dawn or worse during the night would find leopards and leopards and bears in the room and some even died basically of a heart attack when they woke up to find they were sleeping next to a leopard yeah so so he's i mean he's a
的交际花，呃……”然后把灯关掉。他们醒来后发现自己身边躺着的是干瘪的老太婆——是的，来自埃塞俄比亚的老巫婆。是的，在《奥古斯都……》但我以为你要说的是他做的事是……呃，这里写道，当他的朋友们喝醉时，他会把他们关起来，然后在夜里突然放进他的狮子、豹子和熊，所以这是终极的恶作剧——以至于所有这些动物都是无害的，因为它们显然已经被拔掉了牙齿或做了什么手脚，所以他的朋友们在黎明醒来时，或者更糟糕的是在夜里醒来时，会发现房间里有豹子和豹子还有熊，有些人甚至在醒来发现自己和一只豹子睡在一起时直接被吓得心脏病发作了。是的，所以他——我的意思是，他是个
tremendous laugh one more though tom one more one more this is the most banal i think he'll propose to his guests by way of a feat they should invent new sauces for giving flavor to the food and he would offer a large prize for the man who invented the best sauce. On the other hand, if the sauce did not please him, the inventor was ordered to continue eating it until he invented a better one. So when you're turning up with a sauce,
超级搞笑的人。不过还有一个，汤姆，还有一个，还有一个。我认为这是最平庸的一个：他会向他的客人们提议，作为一种比拼，他们应该发明新的酱汁来给食物调味，他会为发明最好酱汁的人提供大奖。另一方面，如果酱汁不能让他满意，发明者就会被命令继续吃那个酱汁，直到他发明出更好的为止。所以当你要端上一款酱汁时，
you've got to keep eating it until you come up with a better one. Well, he's kind of MasterChef with... With leopards. With leopards. I think that would be brilliant. You know who would have enjoyed his parties, Tom? With leopards. With leopards. I think that would be brilliant. You know who would have enjoyed his parties, Tom?
你得一直吃它，直到你想出一个更好的。好吧，他简直是带着……带着豹子的顶级大厨（MasterChef）。我想那会很精彩。你知道谁会喜欢他的派对吗，汤姆？
Dietrich Graf von Hülsenhäsel. Yes, he would. And Ted Kennedy, actually. He'd have loved it as well. Well, actually, so a comment on this from Joseph Evans Green. This episode will surely be awash with absolute lads. I i think basically all these all these guys i mean imagine anyway the famous um party that elegabalus supposedly hosted um is illustrated by the famous painting by lawrence alma todema the kind of dutch painter of classical scenes
迪特里希·格拉夫·冯·许尔森-黑瑟尔（Dietrich Graf von Hülsenhäsel）。是的，他会的。还有泰德·肯尼迪（Ted Kennedy），事实上。他也会非常喜欢的。好吧，事实上，乔·埃文斯·格林对此有一条评论：这个单集肯定充斥着绝对的硬汉小伙儿们。我想基本上所有这些家伙——我的意思是，想象一下……不管怎样，劳伦斯·阿尔玛-塔德玛（Lawrence Alma-Tadema）这位古典场景的荷兰画家创作的那幅名画，描绘了埃拉伽巴尔斯据称举办的著名派对……
um and it shows elegabalus drowning his guests beneath suffocating his guests beneath the rose petals and the story goes that rose petals start to drop down on the guests but they're at the table and everyone's thinking this is delightful how charming and they continue to fall and they continue to fall and they continue to fall until they everyone is dead suffocated by it and when um when alma todema painted this uh very famous painting if you haven't seen it do google it um it was in the dead of winter and so we had to send for rose petals from the french riviera which is kind of great that's very elegabal and behavior in itself well it is and elegabalus was the great hero of the kind of, you know, the decadence and romantics. So kind of wild and people like that.
画中展示了埃拉伽巴尔斯用玫瑰花瓣淹没他的客人，将客人窒息而死。故事说的是，玫瑰花瓣开始落到客人们身上，但他们正坐在桌旁，每个人都觉得这太美妙了、太迷人了，而花瓣还在继续下落，继续下落，继续下落，直到每个人都死了，被它们窒息而死。当阿尔玛-塔德玛画这幅非常著名的画作时——如果你没看过，一定要用谷歌搜一下——那正值严冬，所以他不得不派人从法国里维埃拉运来玫瑰花瓣，这本身就很有埃拉伽巴尔斯的风格。好吧，确实如此，而埃拉伽巴尔斯是那种颓废派和浪漫主义者心目中的伟大英雄。所以有点疯狂的人之类的话。
Aubrey Beardsley-ish kind of people. Aubrey Beardsley, yeah. Antoine Artaud called him the crowned anarchist. What happened to him, Tom? Nothing good. He got murdered. Yeah, he got murdered. Good to do.
奥布里·比亚兹利（Aubrey Beardsley）式的那种人。奥布里·比亚兹利，是的。安东尼·阿尔托（Antoine Artaud）称他为“加冕的无政府主义者”。他怎么了，汤姆？没落得什么好下场。他被谋杀了。是的，他被谋杀了。罪有应得。
Because he can't make people sit on air cushions and next to leopards for that long. One party too far. Yeah. So he's at number five. And I think he's not higher because it probably didn't happen. Yes, that's the issue with this, isn't it? That none of it really happened. Yeah, so that's a shame.
因为你不能让人家坐在气垫上和豹子旁边太久。过头的派对。是的。所以他是第五名。而且我认为他没排得更高，是因为这可能根本没发生过。是的，这就是问题所在，不是吗？这些其实根本没有发生过。是的，所以真遗憾。
I think parties actually have to have happened. But our next party definitely did happen because we've mentioned it on the show before. Number four. That's right, isn't it, Tom? It is, yeah. So this is suggested by james lavender and we then have an honorable mention well so it's the black dinner it's a scott it's the first scottish party of the uh of the top 10 and we also because this is really a sort of um a devolved
我觉得派对实际上得是发生过的才行。但我们的下一个派对绝对发生了，因为我们在节目里提到过它。第四名。对吧，汤姆？确实如此，是的。所以这是詹姆斯·拉文德（James Lavender）建议的，我们随后还有一个荣誉提名——嗯，所以这是“黑色晚餐”（The Black Dinner），这是一场苏格兰的派对——这是前十名中的第一个苏格兰派对，而且我们还因为这实际上是一个权力下放
administrations party section because we're also going to be touching on the abigavenny massacre recommended by andrew patterson so, tell us about The Black Dinner. So The Black Dinner, lots of fans of Game of Thrones will have heard of this because it provided the model for the Red Wedding. And it's called The Black Dinner both because it was a terrible thing, but also because it involves the Douglases, who are probably the most powerful of the Lowland families in the late middle ages um they had come to prominence during the scottish wars of independence um and you have uh sir james douglas uh who was known to the scots as the good douglas yeah and to the english as black douglas because he was he was such a kind of proficient
政府的派对环节，因为我们还将触及安德烈·帕特森（Andrew Patterson）推荐的阿韦加文尼大屠杀（Abergavenny Massacre）。那么，给我们讲讲“黑色晚餐”吧。好的，“黑色晚餐”，很多《权力的游戏》粉丝都听说过这个，因为它为“红色婚礼”提供了原型。它被称为“黑色晚餐”，不仅因为它是一件可怕的事情，还因为它涉及道格拉斯家族（Douglases），他们可能是中世纪晚期低地家族中最强大的势力。他们在苏格兰独立战争期间崭露头角，
fighter against them um and he he's he is the guy who gets charged by robert bruce to take his heart to the holy land and he takes a wrong turning and ends up in spain where where where he dies fighting the moors and um bruce's heart is brought back and buried, I think, in, is it Melrose? I think it's Melrose. It might be Melrose, yeah. And the Earl of Douglas is known as Black Douglas. The Earl of Angus, who's another kind of family, and this, again, going back to Macbeth, the complexities of Scottish families are known as the Red Douglases.
其中有一位詹姆斯·道格拉斯爵士（Sir James Douglas），苏格兰人称他为“好道格拉斯”（the good Douglas），而英国人则称他为“黑道格拉斯”（Black Douglas），因为他对英作战时非常老练、骁勇善战。他就是那个受罗伯特·布鲁斯（Robert Bruce）委托将心脏带到圣地的人。他走错了路，最终在西班牙与摩尔人的战斗中阵亡。布鲁斯的心脏被带了回来，并被埋葬在——我想是在梅尔罗斯（Melrose）？我想是梅尔罗斯。可能是梅尔罗斯，是的。道格拉斯伯爵被称为“黑道格拉斯”。安格斯伯爵（The Earl of Angus）是另一个分支家族，这又得回到《麦克白》了，苏格兰家族关系的复杂性，他们被称为“红道格拉斯”。
And the Black Dinner takes place in 1440 so that's several generations after um the original Douglas um and it involves it's not an uncle murdering his nephew but it's a great uncle yeah murdering the 16 year old William Douglas isn't it yeah who is the sixth yeah the sixth Earl of Douglas um and his brother. So it's quite Richard III. But this is also a children's party, which is worse, because they're invited to dinner with James II of Scotland, who's 10 years old. Yeah.
“黑色晚餐”发生在1440年，那是最初的道格拉斯之后好几代人的事了。这涉及的不是叔叔谋杀侄子，而是曾叔父谋杀16岁的威廉·道格拉斯（William Douglas），对吧？他是第六代——第六代道格拉斯伯爵，还有他的弟弟。所以这非常有《理查三世》的风格。但这同时也是一个儿童派对，这就更糟糕了，因为他们是被邀请与10岁的苏格兰国王詹姆斯二世（James II of Scotland）共进晚餐。是的。
And while they're eating, they're having a lovely dinner. James II is having a wonderful time. And while they're eating, the servants bring in a black bull's head, which is meant to be... They couldn't get a magician. Yeah. It's basically, when they bring in this black bull's head, which is meant to be... They couldn't get a magician. Yeah. It's basically, when they bring in this black bull's head, it's a symbol of death.
当他们正在吃东西的时候，他们度过了一个美好的晚餐时光。詹姆斯二世正过得很愉快。而当他们正在吃东西时，仆人们端上了一个黑色的公牛头，这本该是——他们找不到魔术师。是的。基本上，当他们端上这个黑色的公牛头时，这象征着死亡。
This is the equivalent of the black spot from Treasure Island, isn't it? At that point, these two... So William Douglas is 16. He's turned up with his younger brother. At this point, when the black bull's head makes his appearance, they're dragged out, aren't they? And basically beheaded.
这就相当于《金银岛》里的黑券（black spot），对吧？就在那时，这两个人——威廉·道格拉斯当时16岁，他和弟弟一起出席。就在这时，当黑色公牛头出现时，他们被拖了出去，对吧？然后基本上被斩首了。
Is that right, Tom? Yeah. After a kind of fake trial. And they're beheaded so that one of the people who's organised it is also a Douglas, so that he can basically get the wealth and titles and the earldom. Well, that's the great uncle. Right.
是这样的吗，汤姆？是的。经过一场假审判之后。他们被斩首了，这样组织这场阴谋的人之一也是道格拉斯家族的成员，他就能借此获得财富、头衔和伯爵领地。嗯，那就是曾叔父。没错。
James, yeah. It's very bad. Very bad form. Walter Scott writes a poem about this. Tom, do you want to know how it goes? Yeah, I'd love to. I'd love a bit of poetry. Edinburgh Castle, town and tower.
詹姆斯，是的。太恶劣了。行径极其恶劣。沃尔特·司各特（Walter Scott）为此写过一首诗。汤姆，你想知道它是怎么写的吗？是的，我很想听。我很喜欢来点诗歌。爱丁堡城堡，城镇与高塔。
God grant thou sink for sin. And that in for the black dinner, old Douglas Gatt therein. Who knows what that means? I don't know what that means, but anyways, that was a very powerful... The Scotsman would give that more than one star, I think. A wonderful flavour of what the world missed
愿上帝保佑你因罪沉沦。在那场黑色晚餐中，老道格拉斯命丧其中。谁知道这是什么意思？我不知道这是什么意思，但无论如何，那是一个非常有影响力的……我想苏格兰人会给它打不止一颗星。完美还原了当你失去扮演《麦克白》的机会时，世界所错失的风采。或者说沃尔特·司各特。那么，说起伟大的戏剧表演。所以阿韦加文尼大屠杀，你熟悉这个吗？不，但我看到这是安德烈·帕特森建议的。所以阿韦加文尼大屠杀与这个或罗斯吉尔德屠杀没什么不同。我们在威尔士边区（Welsh marches）。
when you were denied the chance to play Macbeth. Or indeed Walter Scott. Well, now talking of great dramatic portrayals. So the Abergavenny Massacre, are you familiar with this? No, but I saw it had been suggested by Andrew Patterson. So the Abergavenny Massacre is not dissimilar from this or from the Ross Gilder, carry on. We're on the Welsh marches.
威廉·德·布鲁斯（William de Braose），他是个某种边区领主，他邀请了一个叫西齐尔特（Sitzelt）的人和所有波伊斯（Powys）酋长在圣诞节参加一场宴会。他们打算冰释前嫌、握手言和，
William de Breaux who's a sort of marcher lord he invites a man called Sitzelt and all the powess chieftains to a feast at Christmas they're going to bury all the hatchets and be great pals
度过一段美好的时光，这是一个经典的《权力的游戏》风格的故事。他们盛装赴宴，圣诞盛宴，把武器堆在角落里，啤酒源源不断，突然大门被反锁，威廉·德·布鲁斯的手下冲进来把所有人大肆屠杀。威廉·德·布鲁斯赢得了“阿韦加文尼食人魔”的绰号，从此阿韦加文尼城堡便带有这种背叛和谋杀的阴影。所以这是一个……而且他谋杀的其他人是威尔士人？他们是威尔士人。他们是威尔士人。
and have a wonderful time it's a classic Game of Thrones style story they pitch up Christmas feast, stack the weapons in a corner ale is flowing um suddenly the doors are barred william de bros's men come rush in and massacre everybody william de bros earns the the name the ogre of abogavenny and abogavenny castle has this taint of of treachery and and murder ever since so this is and other people he's murdering Welsh? They're Welsh. They are Welsh.
所以这是一种……嗯，他自己也不是英国人，对吧？不，他是个诺曼底的边区领主。但诡异的是：这个家伙，不管是谁建议的“阿韦加文尼大屠杀”——是谁建议的来着？安德烈·帕萨姆（Andrew Passam）。我想我去读读这个。我看到布肯比肯斯国家公园（Brecon Beacons National Park）官网上有一篇关于它的长文。因为显然这件事就发生在那个地方。我查了一下，发现布肯比肯斯国家公园的官网上确实有一篇散文，显然是威廉·德·布鲁斯写的，用唐纳德·特朗普的风格为自己辩护。你敢相信吗？这太诡异了。那些不理解的人，他们只相信骗子和喷子。那些无法自己判断真相的人。他们叫我阿韦加文尼的食人魔。错。我召集了一支队伍，真正伟大且有才华的人、爱国者，来非常顺利、非常有效、非常高效地策划我们如何能一劳永逸地击败这些恐怖分子，让边区重获文明的安全，让王冠再次伟大。我的众多敌人、失败者和嫉妒者歪曲了这个故事。圣诞大捷的消息没有得到它应有的赞誉。
So this is a kind of... Well, he's not English, is he? No, he's a Norman kind of marcher. But here's the weird thing. So this fellow, whoever it was suggested Abergavenny Massacre. Who was it who suggested it? Andrew Passam. I thought I'll read up on this. I saw there was a big thing on the Brecon Beacons National Park
我们保持坚强。我们赢得了伟大的胜利，一场真正伟大的胜利。它基本上就是这样持续了好几个小时，解释为什么在阿韦加文尼的大屠杀中，他受到了失败者和骗子、假新闻媒体以及所有这些东西的虐待和不公对待。这作为国家公园的官网内容实在是太诡异了，但它偏偏就在那儿。好吧，我喜欢这个。所以你没料到那个故事会拐向那个方向，但它确实拐了。
official website about it. Because obviously it's taking place there. I had a look, and there is an essay on the Brecon Beacons National Park website, written apparently by William de Breaux, defending himself in the style of Donald Trump. Can you believe that? It's so weird. People who don't understand, they only believe liars and haters. People who fail to make up their own minds as to the truth. They call me the ogre of Abergavenny. Wrong. I gathered a team, truly great and talented men, patriots, to plan very smoothly, very effectively, very efficiently, how we could defeat these terrorists once and for all and make the marches safe for civilization and make the crown great again. My many enemies, losers, and jealous people have misrepresented this story. The news of the Christmas victory did not get the praise it deserved.
所以灾难性的派对确实可以产生（你知道的）极其搞笑的后果。好吧，这非常顺利地把我们引到了——引到了第三名，我认为这是一个真正糟糕的派对——我的意思是，这是一个糟糕透顶的派对，自从我多年前读了巴巴拉·塔克曼（Barbara Tuchman）的《远方之镜》（A Distant Mirror）以来，它就一直烙印在我的脑海里，那是我大约12岁时最喜欢的书之一。是的，这就是——巴陀盛会（Bal des Ardents）结束了，查理六世，燃烧之人的舞蹈——被烈火吞噬的人的舞蹈。这就是查理六世的故事，他在某种程度上可以说是法国的亨利六世——所以这就是——百年战争中的中场休息。因此英国人来了，他们打了克雷西战役、普瓦捷战役，他们基本上在伟大的法国国王查理五世的领导下被逼退了回去。
We stayed strong. We won a great victory, a truly great victory. And it goes on like that for hours, basically, explaining why the massacre at Abergavenny, he's been hard done by, by losers and liars, the fake news media and all this stuff. It's such a weird thing to be on the official National Park website, but there it is. Well, I like that. So you didn't expect that story to take that turn, but it did.
查理五世于1380年去世，他的儿子查理继位，原本也叫查理。他成为查理六世，时年12岁。是的，可怜的家伙，他疯得像个帽匠，汤姆。嗯，他在这个时候还没疯。所以在他的少年时期，他并没有疯。
So disastrous parties can have, you know, hilarious consequences. Well, that brings us very neatly to uh to number three which i think is a truly terrible party uh i mean it's it's an awful party and it's been seared on my mind ever since i read uh barbara tuckman's distant mirror years and years ago one of my favorite books when i was about 12 yes and and this is um the ballad days are done charles the sixth the dance of the dance of the kind of burning people yeah dance of the people set on fire and this is the story of charles the sixth who in in a way is the kind of the henry the sixth of france so this is um this is kind of the interval in the hundred years war so the english have come they fought chrissy therefore poitier they've basically been kind of forced back out under that great French king, Charles V.
他到了成年的时候，开始执政。我们有——各个公爵，其中包括我们的老朋友勃艮第公爵——勇敢的菲利普。是的，听过我们的勃艮第播客的人可能还记得查理六世，以及他后来对自己深信不疑的那些事——所以周围全都是各种各样的掠夺成性的公爵等等。而在1392年，查理六世开始着迷于一个想法，即这些权势熏天的巨头中有人想要除掉他。而他已经退守到布列塔尼。于是查理下令组织一支入侵部队从巴黎出发去攻打布列塔尼。他正骑着马前行。
Charles V has died in 1380 and he's succeeded by his son, Charles, originally named Charles. He becomes Charles VI, aged 12. Yeah. Poor fellow, he's as mad as a hatter, Tom. Well, he's not at this point. So in his kind of teenage years, he's not.
由于天气非常炎热、尘土飞扬，他与大部队保持了一段距离，他不想让同行伙伴们的马匹踢起的尘土吸进鼻子里。他正骑着马，突然一个赤脚的疯子从树林里跑出来，伸手试图抓住他的缰绳，并大喊：“不要再前进了，高贵的国王！回去吧，你被背叛了！”他跟着国王一路大喊大叫了大约半个小时。
He comes of age, he starts ruling we have um various dukes among them um our old friend the duke of burgundy well the bold yeah he they listen to our burgundy podcast may remember charles the sixth um and what what he later believes about himself all these so there are all these kind of various predatory dukes and so on hanging around. And in 1392, Charles VI becomes obsessed with the idea that one of these kind of powerful magnates is out to get him. And he's retreated to Brittany. And so Charles orders an invasion force to go out from Paris to invade Brittany. And he's riding along. and he is apart from the rest of the group because it's very hot it's very dusty he doesn't want to get the dust that's been kicked up by all his partner's horses in his nose and he's riding along and suddenly a barefoot madman comes running
这显然非常、非常令人不适，对这位在酷热中开始感到有些头晕目眩的国王来说非常不安。他们停了下来。接着，他的一名侍从掉落了一支长矛，长矛铿锵一声撞击在头盔上。突然，国王彻底发疯了，他拔出剑，坚信自己遭到了袭击——遭到他人的袭击，他开始攻击自己的人民——他攻击了自己的兄弟，路易，奥尔良公爵路易——他不得不被制服。勃艮第公爵菲利普控制了局势，他们返回巴黎，在冬天的调养下，国王恢复到了一种脆弱的健康状态。而在整个冬季，
out of the woods and reaches up and tries to hold his bridle and he shouts out ride no further noble king turn back you were betrayed and he follows the king shouting this for about half an hour. And it's obviously very, very uncomfortable, very unsettling for the king who's starting to feel a bit dizzy in the heat. And they stop. And then one of his pages drops a lance and it clangs against the helmet. And suddenly the king goes completely mad and he draws his sword and he's convinced that he's being attacked by um by people he starts attacking his own uh his own um party he attacks his brother yeah duke of orleo louis the duke of orleo uh and he has to be kind of overpowered and philip duke of burgundy seizes control of the situation they head back to paris and the king is nursed back to a precarious kind of health uh by winter and over the winter season
每个人都决定，让国王开心、让他的精神恢复正常的方法就是举办一连串的派对。所以就是恶作剧，无休止的恶作剧，对吧，詹姆斯？疯狂的恶作剧。而在1月28日，他的妻子伊萨博（Isabeau）王后正在庆祝她最喜欢的一位宫廷女官的第三次婚礼。当时的习俗是，当你庆祝一个结过婚的人的婚礼时，你会举办一场特别喧闹的派对。是的，你以一种不那么——我敢说，不那么神圣的方式来庆祝它，汤姆。一种不那么神圣的方式，是的。所以礼节都被抛到了九霄云外。这就像唐宁街一样。
they just everyone decides that the way to to get the king you know happy to get him functioning is to provide a whole series of parties so tomfoolery just endless tomfoolery isn't it james yeah mad capery um and on the 28th of january his wife isabelabel, Isabeau, the queen, she is celebrating the third wedding of one of her favourite ladies-in-waiting. And it's the custom when you celebrate the wedding of someone who's already been married that you kind of have particularly riotous behaviour. Yeah, you do it in a less, dare I say, a less sacral way, Tom. A less sacral way, yes. So decorum is thrown to the winds. It's like Downing Street.
有一个非常讨厌的家伙叫于盖·德·吉西（Huguet de Guissy），他极其令人厌恶。他特别的派对把戏是，如果哪个仆人冒犯了他，他就会强迫仆人趴在地板上，然后把长着马刺的靴子踩在仆人的背上，大喊：“叫啊，狗，叫！”哦，这有点像《继承之战》，对吧？“地板上的野猪”。那一集非常成功。而于盖决定，如果大家都打扮成树木、森林里的野人，那将会有极大的乐趣，而且在国王精神状况有些不稳定和脆弱的时候，这显然是个绝妙的主意。于是他们用松脂涂满全身，并加上各种树枝、木块和细枝。
And there's a very unpleasant guy called Huguet de Guissy, who is very, very unpleasant. And his particular party trick is if a servant offends him, he kind of forces the servant to fall down on the floor and he puts his spurred boot on the back of the servant and he shouts out bark dog bark oh it's a bit like succession yeah the boar on the floor very successful that episode um and ugo decides that it would be tremendous fun and obviously brilliant when the king is a little bit precarious and fragile, if they all dress up as trees, as kind of wild men of the trees. So they coat themselves in pitch and they add various branches,
还有一些头发和皮毛之类的东西，对吧？他们都戴着面具，这样谁也认不出他们是谁。由于他们显然知道这是一个火灾隐患——我的意思是，这也是刺激的一部分，你知道的，你在与死神跳舞——因此下达了非常严格的命令，任何人都不准拿着火炬。没错。所以他们有六个人，全都冲进了王后和她的女官正在庆祝婚礼的地方，开始跳舞、大喊下流话，高喊着下流话。没有人知道他们是谁，
bits of wood, bits of twig. And sort of hair and fur and stuff, isn't it? And they all wear masks so that nobody can see who they are. And because obviously they understand that this is a fire hazard i mean that's part of the thrill of it you know that you're dicing with death very strict orders are given that no one is to have a torch that's right so there are six of them they all go rushing in to where the queen and her lady-in-waiting is celebrating the nuptials and they start dancing and shouting obscenities shouting obscenities nobody knows who they are
是的，但你知道的——但这就是人们所期待的。接着，灾难降临了，国王的弟弟、奥尔良公爵路易走了进来，他没有听到命令。他有点微醺，手里拿着一根火炬。手里拿着火炬。而火星点燃了其中一个狂欢者身上的松脂，瞬间就“呼”地一声燃起来了。王后尖叫起来，因为她知道她的丈夫就是这六个跳舞的人之一。
yeah but you know but this is what people have been expecting. And then disastrously, Louis, the king's brother, the Duke of Orléans, comes in and he hasn't heard the orders. He's a bit tipsy and he's carrying a torch. Carries a torch. And a spark catches the pitch on the bodies of one of the revelers. And it just goes whoosh. And the queen screams because she knows that her husband is one of these six dancing men.
但他的姑姑，当时只有15岁，穿着一件巨大的礼服，极其巨大的礼服。贝里公爵的裙子。她把裙子盖在国王身上，基本上是为了扑灭他的——你知道的，保护他免受火焰伤害，并扑灭附着在他身上的任何火花。但随后其他五个人全都像蜡烛一样烧了起来，对吧？其中一个人跳进了冰酒桶里。他确实跳了，当然。是的，他跳了。所以有两个人活了下来。
But his aunt, who is only 15, is wearing a massive dress, colossal dress. A chest of berry. And she throws her skirt over him to basically put out his, you know, to protect him from the flames and to put out any sparks that have attached themselves to him. But then the other five all go up like candles, don't they? One of them jumps into a wine cooler. He does, of course. Yes, he does. So two of them survive.
南图耶勋爵（Sieur de Nantouillet）跳进了一个大酒桶里——凯恩公爵风格的那种，跳进了一个大酒桶里。但其他人——他没事，呃，是的，其他人——其他的，有一个当场死亡，两个苦苦挣扎了两天，然后因烧伤死去了。至于于盖·德·吉西，他在三天后死去，然后被放入棺材，送葬队伍穿过巴黎。当队伍穿过巴黎街道时，所有人都在大喊：“叫啊，狗，叫！”天哪，当然这把国王彻底逼疯了。我正想说，这对查理的心理健康可不太好。不，这对他的心理健康毫无益处。有时他在半夜醒来——哦，汤姆，要是他听了你的广告就好了——我知道，
The sieur de Nantouillet, he jumps into a big vat of sort of Duke of Cairns style, jumps into a vat of wine. But the others. He's all right um yeah the others the others so one dies on the spot yeah two two linger kind of for two days and then die of their burns and then huger the gc he dies after three days and he gets put in his coffin and the cortege go through paris and as it goes through the streets of Paris everyone shouts out bark dog bark oh my word well and of course this drives the king completely around the twist I was about to say this isn't good for Charles's mental health no it's not good for his mental health sometimes he wakes up in the middle of the night oh Tom if only he'd listen to your ads I know um
纳闷着：我什么时候才能不再发疯？是的，他不会停下来的，因为他觉得自己是玻璃做的之类的一大堆。这是一个非常悲伤的故事，可怜的查理。但这对亨利五世很有利——所以最终一切都有了美满的结局。没错，所以我想——我认为这在某种程度上可以说是最令人心碎的，或许也是相当悲剧的。好吧，接下来的这个派对非常悲剧，所以第二名——克莱尔·杰伊（Claire Jay）建议了这个。我很高兴她这么提议，因为我认为这是我们谈论灾难性派对时我想到的第一个派对之一。所以某种程度上可以说是节目的朋友，或者说是节目的悲剧朋友，我应该这么说：尼古拉和亚历山大，俄罗斯的末代沙皇和沙皇后，他们在
wondering will I ever stop being mad yeah he won't because he he thinks he's made of glass and all that kind of stuff that's a very sad story poor charles and but it's good for henry v yeah so it's so it all ends happily in the end yes right so that's i think i think that's i mean in a way the most upsetting perhaps that's quite tragic well this next party is very tragic so number two um claire jay suggested this i'm glad she did because I suggest it was one of the first parties I thought of when we talked about disastrous parties. So sort of friends of the show or sort of tragic friends of the show, I should say, uh, Nicholas and Alexandra, the last Tsar and Tsarina of Russia, they are getting crowned
1896年5月在克林姆林宫的乌斯佩斯基大教堂（Uspensky Cathedral）加冕。为了庆祝最新的罗曼诺夫沙皇，筹办了各种大规模的庆祝活动和盛会。并且将会在莫斯科郊外的霍登卡平原（Khodynka Field）举办一场巨大的派对，也就是节日宴会。具体的筹办方式是，他们搭建了某种仿制剧院，也就是木制剧院。他们搭建了各种看台。
in May, 1896, um, at the Uspensky Cathedral in the Kremlin. And there are all kinds of massive celebrations and festivities arranged to celebrate the latest kind of Romanov Tsar. And there's going to be a huge party, sort of festival banquet at Kadinka Field, based on the outskirts of Moscow. So the way that's going to work is they put up a sort of mock theatres, kind of wooden theatres. They put up all kinds of stands.
他们建造了20个酒吧。现在，在活动举办地附近，有这样一个布满沟壑和峡谷的田野，它有点像是一片坑坑洼洼的荒地。但这没关系。每个人都会赶来并度过一段绝妙的时光。现在，他们被告知在5月29日的晚上——所以他们将要赶来度过一段绝妙的时光。现在，他们被告知在5月
They've built 20 bars. Now, near where it's going to happen, there's this field with kind of all gullies and ravines, and it's a bit kind of raggedy field. But that's fine. Everyone's going to turn up and have a tremendous time. Now, they are told by the evening of the 29th of May, so it's going to turn up and have a tremendous time. Now they are told by the evening of the
29日的晚上——也就是第二天，在5月29日，莫斯科流传起一个谣言，说当这个派对举行时，将会有各种各样的礼物发给民众。基本上就是你能得到的礼物——现在这些听起来可能对你来说算不了什么，汤姆，但对于1896年的莫斯科人来说，
29th of May, so it's going to be the next day, on the 29th of May, the rumor goes around Moscow that there are going to be all kinds of gifts given to the people when this party takes place. So basically the gifts you get, now these may not sound like much to you, Tom, but people of Moscow in 1896,
一个面包卷、一块香肠、一些椒盐卷饼、一些姜饼和一个纪念杯。这听起来比火人节（Fyre Festival）要好。是的，比火人节好得多。所以人们对此感到非常兴奋。谣言四起，说杯子里会有一枚金币，这让人们感到非常、非常兴奋。因此，在派对当天的黎明时分，已经有成千上万的人涌入这片田野。基本上，这是一个经典的情况。
a bread roll, a piece of sausage, some pretzels, some gingerbread, and a commemorative cup. Which sounds better than the Fyre Festival. Yeah, it's a lot better than the Fyre Festival. So people are very excited about this. And the rumor goes around that in the cup, there will be a gold coin, which people are very, very excited by. So by dawn on the morning of the party, there are thousands of people already streaming onto this field. Basically, it's the classic thing.
当局没有预料到会有这么大的需求。他们只配备了大约2000名警察，但这远远不足以控制人群。接着谣言四起——随着清晨的到来，兴奋情绪高涨，谣言四起，说他们将分发完椒盐卷饼和啤酒，人群顿时变得非常激动，并向摊位蜂拥而去。正如我所说，那片田野坑坑洼洼、布满沟渠，人们开始跌入沟渠，更多的人压在他们身上，基本上……至少有1200人在这次派对中被踩踏致死，还有
The authorities haven't anticipated the demand. They provided about 2,000 policemen, but that's nowhere near enough to control the crowds. And then a rumour goes around, sort of as the excitement mounts the morning wears on a rumor goes around um that they are going to run out of pretzels and beer and the crowd all get very excited and they stampede towards the the stalls and as i said the field is kind of ragged and pitted and there's ditches and stuff people start to fall into a ditch more people part on top of them and basically um at least 1 200 people are crushed to death at this at this party and there
成千上万的人——甚至可能多达2万人——受了重伤。所以这是一个绝对骇人听闻、极其可怕的场面。非同寻常的是，节日还在继续。所以沙皇和亚历山大在两点左右露面了，此时死者已经被运走了。然后那天晚上，他们继续去参加法国大使举办的舞会，不是吗？法国大使馆，没错。尼古拉在日记中写下了这件事，他说：“你知道的，这是一场可怕的事故，太可怕了、太可怕了，诸如此类。”但由于他是一个非常——他和亚历山大都是非常克制、有些神经质、焦虑而严肃的人——他们没有像戴安娜王妃那样去大发感慨、表露情绪，不，他们去教堂了，正是如此。而每个人都说——无论如何——
are thousands upon thousands more perhaps as many as 20 000 who are badly injured so it's an absolutely appalling ghastly scene the extraordinary thing is the festival continues so the czar and alexandra they turn up at about two o'clock by which time the dead have been taken away um and then that evening they go on to a ball at the at the french ambassador isn't it the french embassy exactly now nicholas writes about this in his diary and he says you know it's um it was a terrible mishap and awful awful and all this but because he's a very he and alexandra are very controlled slightly neurotic anxious serious people they don't do a kind of princess diana and go and emote and no they go to church they exactly and everybody says whatever it is and
每个人都说，“你知道的，他们根本不在乎。”所以从一开始，许多人就说——首先，这被称为“血腥尼古拉”，“血腥尼古拉”，正是如此。他从一开始就有了这个外号。这是个不祥之兆，预示着他的统治将是一个悲剧。当然，之所以这是一个可怕的预兆的原因之一是，在一个极其不平等、分裂、狂热的社会里，这是最糟糕的开端。你知道的，任何编剧都无法想象出一个比这更能证明你拥有一个冷酷无情、高高在上的精英阶层以及一个饱受践踏、压迫的底层多数派更好的场景了。正如你一直所说的那样，真正灾难性派对的关键在于，它像一面镜子，映照出了
everybody says you know they don't care they don't so right from the beginning lots of people say um well first of all it's called bloody nicholas bloody nicholas exactly this is he has his nickname right from the beginning it's ill-fated that this is a terrible omen for his reign but of course the reason that one of the reasons it's a terrible omen is that in a very unequal divided febrile society it's the worst possible start and you know no script writer could imagine a scene better calculated to prove that you have an uncaring aloof elite and a downtrodden oppressed majority and as you've said all along the key to a really disastrous party is that it holds a mirror up to
社会的裂痕——确切地说，正是社会内部的病态，而这显然非常有力地做到了这一点。好吧，所以我认为这无疑是一场糟糕透顶的派对。我们现在来到了我们选择的第一名。是的。这其实有点作弊，因为我们其实已经讨论过它了。好吧，但这其实是把两个派对合并成了一个列表，汤姆。所以这就是我们选择它的原因，
fractures exactly exactly pathologies within a society which obviously this does very powerfully. Right. So I think that's indisputably a terrible party. We now come to our choice of number one. Yeah. And there's a bit of a cheat this, because we have actually already discussed it. Well, it's two parties in one list, this though, Tom. So that's why we've chosen it,
因为这是一场跨越世纪、余波回荡并催生了第二场灾难性派对的灾难性派对。所以我们选出的历史上最具灾难性的派对是：亚历山大大帝火烧波斯波利斯（Persepolis）。好吧，这基本上就是把波斯波利斯当作一个派对场地来办，我想是这样的。是的。所以给我们讲讲亚历山大吧，汤姆。好吧，我们有西蒙·詹姆斯·乔治——没有多少派对能失控到这种地步。是的，所以亚历山大——所以约瑟夫·埃文斯·
because this is a disastrous party that echoes down the centuries and gives birth to a second disastrous party. So we have chosen as our most disastrous party in history, Alexander burning down Persepolis, Alexander the Great. Well, it's basically Persepolis as a party venue. I think this isn't it. Yeah. So tell us about Alexander, Tom. Well, we've got simon james george not many parties get that out of hand yeah so alex alexander so joseph evans
格林曾说过，这一集将充斥着绝对的硬汉小伙儿。亚历山大显然是终极的硬汉小伙，他实际上经历了三场灾难性的派对。首先是为了庆祝他的父亲菲利普而举办的派对。菲利普再婚了，喝醉了，跌倒了。而亚历山大对父亲再婚感到非常恼火，带着轻蔑的口吻——这是在菲利普正计划入侵波斯的时候——说道：
green had said that this episode will be a wash with absolute lads alexander is obviously the ultimate lad uh and he he features in three disastrous parties really really. So there's the party that is held to celebrate his father, Philip. He gets remarried, gets drunk, stumbles. And Alexander, who's very miffed that his father has remarried, kind of dismissively, this is when Philip is planning to invade Persia, says,
“马其顿人啊，希腊各邦竟然有这样一位优秀的英雄来领导他们的军队从欧洲开赴亚洲！他连一张桌子走到另一张桌子都走不稳，就会摔倒。”上面写着：“马其顿人啊，何等优秀的英雄啊。希腊各邦竟由他来率领军队从欧洲远征亚洲。他甚至连一张桌子挪到另一张桌子都走不稳就会摔倒。”菲利普试图杀了他。亚历山大逃跑了。这一切都糟透了。
men of Macedon, what a fine hero the states of Greece have to lead their armies from Europe to Asia. He's not able to pass from one table to another without falling. It says, men of Macedon, what a fine hero. The states of Greece have to lead their armies from Europe to Asia. He's not able to pass from one table to another without falling. Philip tries to kill him. Alexander runs away. It's all terrible.
但同时，汤姆。这是一场糟糕的婚礼派对。但同时，菲利普——他们办过一场派对，不是吗？为了菲利普的女儿？是亚历山大的姐姐要结婚吗？菲利普就是在那里被暗杀的。是的，那是另一个。菲利普在举办派对方面的记录糟糕透顶。
But also, Tom. It's a bad wedding party. But also, Philip, they had a party, didn't they, for Philip's daughter? Was it Alexander's sister who was getting married? And that's where Philip was assassinated. Yes, that's another one. Philip has a terrible record with parties.
所以那是一场糟糕的派对。好吧，所以有四个，所以那是一场糟糕的派对。然后是黑克利图斯（Black Clitus）的谋杀案，菲利普的朋友，亚历山大的某种导师。亚历山大老保姆的兄弟。是的，他们大吵了一架，结果亚历山大用长矛把他刺死了。那是在撒马尔罕，对吧？
So that's a bad one. Okay, so there's four, so that's a bad one. Then there's the murder of Black Clitus, friend of Philip, kind of mentor to Alexander. The brother of Alexander's old nanny. Yeah, so they have a massive bust up and Alexander ends up scurrying him with a spear. That's in Samarkand, isn't it?
这次是在公元前330年。亚历山大在三场伟大的战役中击败了波斯人。第三场是在高加米拉（Gaugamela），大流士三世已经逃跑了。因此美索不达米亚和波斯现在都归亚历山大所有了。于是他
This one is 330. Alexander has defeated the Persians in three great battles. The third one at Gaugamela, Darius III, has fled. So Mesopotamia and Persia are now Alexander's. So he
去了巴比伦，然后骑马前往波斯波利斯，那是……这座城市最能象征波斯王朝——阿契美尼德王朝（Achaemenids）权力的象征，而这个王朝已经被亚历山大推翻了。尽管亚历山大通常希望宣称自己继承了波斯帝国的遗产，但在这次事件中，他显然已经决定波斯波利斯应该被毁灭，他要发表一个声明：阿契美尼德时代已经结束，他是波斯的新国王。故事记载，他在庆祝攻占波斯波利斯的狂欢中醉得一塌糊涂。
goes to Babylon, and then he rides up to Persepolis, which is the... It's the city that most symbolizes the power of the Persian dynasty, the Achaemenids, whom Alexander has toppled. And although generally Alexander wants to lay claim to the inheritance of the Persian empire, on this occasion, clearly he has decided that Persepolis should go, that he will be making a statement that the Achaemenid era is over and that he is the new king of Persia. And the story goes that he is celebrating capture of Persepolis, riotously drunk. And there is a courtesan there, Hetera, called Teis, who is the mistress of Ptolemy,
现场有一位交际花，名妓（Hetera），名叫苔伊斯（Thais），她是托勒密的情妇——也就是我们那个带着会说话的蛇的朋友，他后来成了埃及国王。她是雅典人。而其中一位波斯国王——薛西斯，在公元前480年入侵希腊期间曾烧毁过雅典卫城。于是她说：“让我们复仇吧。烧毁波斯波利斯吧。”于是故事说，当时已经喝得酩酊大醉的亚历山大和这帮人——苔伊斯在一旁为他们摇旗呐喊——一把火烧了这座宫殿。他们把所有的火炬都扔了进去，对吧？扔进了薛西斯的
our friend with the talking snakes, who subsequently becomes king of Egypt. And she is Athenian. And one of the Persian kings, Xerxes, had burnt the Acropolis during the invasion of Greece in 480 BC. And she says, let's have vengeance. Let's burn Persepolis. And so the story goes that Alexander, very drunk by this point, and all the gang, Paius kind of cheering them them on incinerate the palace. They throw all these torches don't they into the Xerxes
千柱殿（the hall with the thousand columns）或类似名字的地方。那些远比希腊任何建筑都要宏伟的奇妙建筑。近东世界中最精美、最辉煌的权力的宣示。通常是由希腊人雕刻的。但
the hall with the thousand columns or whatever it's called. The fantastic buildings that are far greater than anything in Greece. The finest most splendid statements of power in the sort of near eastern world. Often sculpted by Greeks. But
千柱之厅或不管它叫什么。那些远比希腊任何建筑都更加宏伟的奇妙建筑。近东世界中最好、最宏伟的权力宣示。通常由希腊人雕刻。但是
they're absolutely, you know, you know a lot of made of wood so it all burns down um these rafters come crashing down it's a terrible scene but as you say it resounds down the centuries because it becomes that party becomes the sort of template doesn't it for it's the sort of it's it's the ultimate symbol of hubris and sort of drunkenness and all this kind of stuff and actually that our next persepolis party has also become a symbol of hubris though some historians think slightly unfairly so let's go more than 2 000 years forward in time we're in 19 just to nathan hogg for suggesting this yeah very good suggestion. We're in 1971, on October 1971, and it is the 2,500th anniversary of Persia?
它们绝对，你知道，你知道很多是用木头做的，所以全都烧成了灰烬，嗯，这些椽子轰然倒塌，这是一个可怕的场景。但正如你所说，它在几个世纪里回响，因为它成为了那个派对的某种模板，不是吗？它是那种傲慢、醉酒以及所有这类事情的终极象征。实际上，我们的下一个波斯帕波利斯派对也成为了傲慢的象征，尽管一些历史学家认为这稍微有点不公平。所以让我们把时间向前推进2,000多年，我们来到了19——感谢内森·霍格（Nathan Hogg）提出这个建议，是的，非常好的建议。我们来到了1971年，1971年10月，这是波斯的2500周年庆典？
No, of Cyrus. Of Cyrus the Great, exactly. And the Shah of Iran, Mohammad Reza Pahlavi, who we talked about in our oil crisis, oil weapon episode. He is very keen to assert Iranian power, modernity, sort of its renewed status in the world to assert his regime and all this stuff. So he organized this colossal party. Some, you know, as with so much of this, like with al-Aqaba's party, how much of this like with alagabas's party how much of this is true is actually difficult to say even though it's very recent because the guinness book of records
不，是居鲁士的。准确地说，是居鲁士大帝的。伊朗国王穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维（Mohammad Reza Pahlavi），我们在石油危机、石油武器那一期节目中讨论过他。他非常热衷于宣示伊朗的力量、现代性以及它在世界上恢复的地位，以宣示他的政权等等。所以他组织了这个宏大的派对。有些人，你知道的，正如这其中的许多事情一样，就像埃拉伽巴卢斯的派对一样，这些事情有多少是真的，其实很难说，尽管这是非常近期的事，因为吉尼斯世界纪录
crowned this the greatest banquet in human history but whether that's really the truth the food is flown in from um from maxims in paris exactly yeah and there's all kinds of there's 250 mercedes limousines um There's dinnerware from the Emoge. There are special plates commissioned from Spode of England. 10,000 plates decorated in turquoise and gold. All this sort of stuff is special. And lots of... So the Queen doesn't go.
将其加冕为人类历史上最伟大的宴会，但这是否真的是事实，食物是从巴黎马克西姆餐厅空运过来的，确实如此，而且有各种各样的东西，有250辆梅赛德斯豪华轿车，还有来自埃莫日（Emoge）的餐具。有专门向英国斯波德（Spode）定制的盘子。10,000个饰有绿松石和金子的盘子。所有这些东西都是特别的。还有很多……所以女王没有去。
Jeke Venimer goes. Nixon doesn't go. Spyro Agnew goes. Spyro Agnew goes. Princess Anne goes. Haile Selassie goes. Yeah, Haile Selassie, Tito, Imelda Marcos Ceausescu, Mobutu
杰基·维尼默去了。尼克松没去。斯皮罗·阿格纽去了。斯皮罗·阿格纽去了。安妮公主去了。海尔·塞拉西去了。是的，海尔·塞拉西、铁托、伊梅尔达·马科斯、齐奥塞斯库、蒙博托
a lot of people who've turned up in the show before they all go so it's an absolutely tremendous occasion if you like dictators or princesses and yeah they have this huge blowout and there's a Son and Lumiere show there's all this kind of stuff.
很多以前在节目中出现过的人都去了，所以如果你喜欢独裁者或公主的话，这绝对是一个极好的场合，他们举行了这场盛大的狂欢，还有一场声光秀（Son et Lumiere），诸如此类的东西。
But what's so interesting is, so the Shah's regime falls sort of seven, eight years later in the Iranian revolution, and the party becomes this metaphor for the hubris of the Shah's regime. It has done ever since. And the estimates of its cost have kind of ballooned and ballooned. But it turns out, so I read, there's an academic study of this by a chap called Robert Steele, and he says a lot of this stuff is just made up.
但最有趣的是，国王的政权大约在七、八年后的伊朗革命中倒台，而这个派对成为了国王政权傲慢的隐喻。从那以后一直如此。对其成本的估计也像滚雪球一样不断膨胀。但事实证明，据我所读，有一个叫罗伯特·斯蒂尔（Robert Steele）的人对此进行过学术研究，他说这里的很多东西都是凭空捏造的。
So there's a claim, for example, they flew in 50,000 songbirds from Europe. And he says, this is just utterly invented. They didn't need to fly in songbirds. There are lots of songbirds in Iran. What happened is that when the revolution took place, in order to basically besmirch the Shahs, I mean, the party was an extravagant blowout, no question, but that people made ever more inflated claims about it
所以有一种说法，例如，他们从欧洲空运了50,000只鸣禽。他说，这完全是捏造的。他们不需要空运鸣禽。伊朗有很多鸣禽。实际情况是，当革命发生时，为了抹黑国王——我的意思是，这个派对是一场极其奢侈的狂欢，毫无疑问——人们对它做出了越来越夸张的宣称
in order to kind of paint the shah as this sort of demented madman. But also it's to attack the very institution of monarchy itself. Exactly. Which is why the fact it's at Persepolis is so potent. And actually, if you go to Persepolis the the frameworks of the tents that they put up which i think were modeled on the field of the cloth of gold yeah um you can still see them so you walk up a path towards the ruins and the kind of the the skeletons the the rusting skeletons of these tents are still there i guess
为了将国王描绘成这样一个精神错乱的疯子。但这也是为了攻击君主制本身的制度。确实如此。这就是为什么它在波斯波利斯举行会如此具有冲击力。事实上，如果你去波斯波利斯，他们搭建的帐篷的框架——我想它们是以金帐汗国（Field of the Cloth of Gold）为原型建造的——是的，你仍然可以看到它们。所以你沿着一条小路走向废墟，这些帐篷的骨架，那些生锈的骨架，依然在那里，我想
as a you know as a reminder exactly as a reminder I mean, all that stuff about the songbirds and everything, I mean, it's interesting, isn't it? Because it does suggest, say, the Aligabalus episode. I mean, you can kind of see how these stories develop and indeed even the story that Alexander tortures it as part of a drunken party. But I agree. It's really the ultimate disastrous party, I think,
作为一个，你知道的，作为一个提醒，完全作为一个提醒。我的意思是，所有关于鸣禽之类的事情，很有趣，不是吗？因为这确实说明了问题，比如埃拉伽巴卢斯的插曲。我的意思是，你可以看出这些故事是如何发展的，甚至包括亚历山大在一次酒宴中将其酷刑折磨的故事。但我同意。这真的是终极灾难性的派对，我想
because it resonates so powerfully. so tom give me your choice so if there's one party if you had to go to one which would you go to and which is one would you least likely like to go to i think for the sheer improbability of it seeing the ballet dance in the black forest that's what i choose i mean i enjoyed that story so much that i would love to have been at that party. Which would you least like to go to? Well, I think the Rose Petals, because then you're going to die. No, no, no. I'd definitely, I'd have, the one I'd least like to go to,
因为它产生了如此强烈的共鸣。所以汤姆，告诉我你的选择，如果只有一个派对，如果你必须去一个，你会去哪一个？哪一个又是你最不想去的？我想由于它的极度匪夷所思，去看黑森林里的芭蕾舞，这就是我的选择。我的意思是，我太喜欢这个故事了，以至于我很想去参加那个派对。你最不想去哪一个？嗯，我想是玫瑰花瓣派对，因为那样你就会死。不，不，不。我绝对，我要去，我最不想去的那个，
surely you must be able to get, I'd hate to go to the Fyre Festival. Yeah. With a load of would-be influencers. But you wouldn't, but the influencers didn't go. I think if I went to that fest, if I'd gone to the Fyre Festival, I mean, it's inconceivable. I can't imagine the scenario in which I would go to the Fyre Festival. But if I had gone, I think I would much rather have been like the Black Dinner or a Mamluk.
你肯定能懂，我讨厌去Fyre音乐节。是的。和一群想当网红的人一起。但你不会去，网红也没去。我想如果我去那个音乐节，如果我去了Fyre音乐节，我的意思是，这简直不可想象。我想象不出我会去Fyre音乐节的情景。但如果我真的去了，我想我宁愿去参加黑色晚宴（Black Dinner）或成为马穆鲁克。
Is your dislike of going to festivals so great that you'd rather be smothered to death beneath rose petals? If it was with the people at the Fyre Festival, I think yes. Well, if there are any influencers who are running massive festivals out there who'd like to invite dominic i mean it'd be a great endorsement for your festival actually if you converted me so yeah i'm very much up for if like any of these bella hadid people want to contact me and invite me to their festival and maybe maybe you could take your tutu yeah i'll go as count von whatever how about that and we may have a new candidate for the most disastrous party of all time exactly anyway thanks ever so much for listening um what have we got coming up dominic we have got oh we've got um
你对去音乐节的厌恶程度，难道已经到了宁愿被玫瑰花瓣活活闷死的地步吗？如果是和Fyre音乐节的人在一起，我想是的。好吧，如果有任何正在举办大型音乐节并想邀请多米尼克的网红在听的话，我的意思是，如果你能把我转化过去，这对你的音乐节来说将是一个很好的背书，所以是的，如果有任何像贝拉·哈迪德这样的人想联系我并邀请我去他们的音乐节，我非常乐意，也许你可以带上你的芭 tutu 裙。是的，我会扮成某某伯爵去，怎么样？我们可能会有一个史上最灾难派对的新候选人。总之，非常感谢你们的收听，嗯，我们接下来有什么节目，多米尼克？我们有，哦，我们有
the last um the last emperor of mexico haven't we that's a very that's a very exciting story very actually quite a few disastrous parties in that i think so thank you very much for listening and we'll see you all next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
墨西哥的最后一位皇帝，不是吗？那是一个非常、非常精彩的故事，其中其实有不少灾难性的派对，我想。非常感谢大家的收听，我们下期再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。